oh is it showtime
hey everybody welcome to fat man beyond
i'm kevin smith
i'm mark bernard
um we have so much to talk about
not the least of which is wanda vision
but as you caught me
reading the manscape daily news mark do
you have a subscription to the manscape
daily news
i'm a charter subscriber to the
miniscape daily news they still got a
comic book section
uh you know they stick comics they still
got want ads and stuff
it's the only paper uh that i still read
you know they've got obituaries my
favorite part
you know the newspaper like my father
used to go looking to see who died and
[ __ ]
um but the headline as you can tell in
the in the manscape news is we save
balls
doesn't this feel like you know that in
the picture of like
huey beats whatever
stewie beats truman that's the dewey
beat's true this is my
dewey beach truman moment right here
yeah see i thought
this was your jay jared jameson moment
where you're like reading the paper and
then something
parker whacker
and parker i'm like angry because he
caught me reading about bald
if we had good pictures of duck off we
wouldn't need to put balls in the
headline
let me tell you something if i'm that
guy i [ __ ] love spider-man because
it's like once you get spider-man you
get a doc
you get a green goblin you're selling
newspapers why he's making hay off this
[ __ ] spider-man instead of like
cutting him a check is beyond me but you
know what that's a story for another
time
i don't want to get on jay jonah
jameson's dick because i don't want to
wind up on the [ __ ]
daily bugle website have you seen that
the daily bugle thing they're doing for
spider-man 3 i have not known tell me
about it
you can go to it flash thompson's
instagram he had a like a
copy of the webpage and you know it kind
of they're
they're building their world before we
get a chance to see it
um and so the dailybugle.net is uh
a website and you could see the page on
on flash thompson's page
instagram page story i think it was um
but wait before we jump into all that
good stuff uh as you can tell ladies and
gentlemen
uh we have the proud uh sponsor with us
tonight
the good folks who tell you your balls
will thank you the good folks at
manscape
ladies and gentlemen manscape right here
this manscape kit
came with what we got here
while i'm digging this [ __ ] out tell
them where to go for manscapes
if you want to get in on some of this
sweet sweet manscaped action go to
manscape.com
use the code fatman20 and you'll get 20
off with free shipping
so go there your balls will thank you
got one of these
oh i do have one of those hold on let me
crack it out of my box here the
lawnmower too
man this little set came with one of
these
and out the box mark it's ready to go
you didn't have to like hear that
that's the sound of pleasure the
pleasure of shaving the pleasure of
holding it against
something that comes but it's ready to
go and [ __ ] this shaver
and then it's got this little bag with
accoutrements in it and what do you got
let me see yours
i got the look at look into the light
forget about all of your hair care words
you're right i got the light too oh my
god we can have a lightsaber fight
this feels more like the flashy thing
from men in black
the neuralizer yes
um here's a little charging cord here's
a little you know in case you're real
[ __ ] thick you
haven't touched him in years and you got
just a thicket to get through down here
what's in this this is a souvenir mug of
some sort what's going on
it's a [ __ ] handy-dandy holder that's
where it goes into and [ __ ] like that
yeah um you plug it in you get ready to
shave your damn balls
uh as as needed right here we got some
ball toner ladies and gentlemen
so you've uncapped that [ __ ] you're like
and you just spray it on
you [ __ ] go and what happens is when
somebody gets into your balls they're
like this shit's tone
and you're like that's right manscape
tone
yes it is putting a star wipe in your
crotch
and star wipe i know this is called the
manscape
uh crop preserver it is ball deodorant
can you believe we've lived long enough
where they can write the words
ball deodorant on a product and they
wouldn't be run out of the [ __ ] state
or something like that
nobody wants sweaty balls truth in
advertising
tell them what it is it's goddamn bald
deodorant
what
hmm here i'll try to pull up
i'll see if we're still on
i'm not sure i've got buffering all over
my internet
although i have you guys on zoom
no we're still up dude i wonder if
restream
are you are you guys i see it on my
house
oh okay we're good we're back sorry the
chat was blowing up and then
you know that just gave uh cfmvm in chat
the ability to say that california
internet sucks
i just want to point out for the record
kids that
you won't see me falling offline this
week or
ever again because i you know what i did
i plugged into the internet no more
[ __ ] wi-fi
after nearly the entire quarantine i
finally figured out well what if i just
plugged into the wall
and josh roush was like that worked much
better so
i won't be none of those frustration
moments where i'm like
and then what i think about wanda is you
know [ __ ]
i'm i've got good internet are you
hardwired in mark are you
no i'm i'm on wi-fi but i'm also on like
weworks
highfalutin you know industrial strength
wi-fi
true true and jc are you wi-fi out are
you hardlined in
hardwired i am hardwired i'm hardwired
in
why did you think we went off the
internet jc free you thought we went off
youtube so we were all looking both uh
both the twitch
and the youtube started buffering on my
end and then everybody in the chat was
like it's buffering
we don't see anything so everybody in
chat now is like it's great we're here
shut up move on
look at all these fine [ __ ] products
the modern man
is a man who takes care of himself
manscaping isn't just for life's
special occasions it's a requirement for
optimal health
superior hygiene and healthy self-esteem
how awesome is that man where do we send
these cats to buy this stuff
they go to manscape.com you use the code
fatman20 save 20 off
and you know like one of these things
that i really appreciate is
i i have in the past given the kind of
hair that i have
gone to like a barber and had the
clippers go and you get these snags
in your head and they would [ __ ] hurt
these bastards the lawnmower 3.0 has a
ceramic blade and advanced skin safe
technology so no snags on your snowballs
at all and the trim is waterproof so
[ __ ] take it in the shower with a
jacuzzi
if you're a savage take it
just like mark said you take it take
take it and you take it good
um if you're willing to use it on your
scalp if it's good enough for your scalp
it's good enough for your balls kids and
marcus the first one to testify
he's told you many times that he uses
his ball shaver man
and he stands by that he hasn't changed
his story in all this time
not at all your head is the balls of the
top of your body so shave them clean
um in this kit it came with a profan
a pair of performance boxer briefs
but this is for a large man so i don't
know who the [ __ ] they think is going to
wear it in this house
i uh i large not for quite some time
it's been a minute since i fit in a
large
so somebody if we were live at the bar
and doing shows somebody was going to
walk out with my panties tonight
oh hell yeah and then there's a t-shirt
manscape your balls will thank you
look at this [ __ ] carrying kit
yeah if you get the performance package
it comes with a lawnmower 3.0 the weed
whacker ear and
nose hair trimmer and the briefs and a
travel bag
and you put it all in this sweet bag
hell yeah
look at this [ __ ] everyone's like we
know how a bag works [ __ ]
that's kind of dope it's a really nice
bag i like these manscaped people not
the least of which because they [ __ ]
sponsor fat man beyond
but god damn it they're going where no
one's gone before man
they're just like putting balls on front
street and let me tell you
nobody likes [ __ ] balls guys don't
like balls
girls don't like balls but they're there
they're an essential part of life
you got to get past them to get to the
good stuff and whatnot why not keep them
looking their best
why not have your balls be their
shiniest man and tonist
that's that what you get with the good
folks at manscape ladies and gentlemen
look at all these fine [ __ ] products
take care of your goddamn balls go to
manscaped.com
what fat man do 20 20. batman 20.
batman 20. look at me make it [ __ ]
making it more difficult
yes it's so [ __ ] good they've left
off the second 20.
go to fat man fatman.com go to
manscape.com
man 20. and what do they get for that
like 20 off with free shipping
20 off of free [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah so go
to that website or go to manscape.com
and put in the code at checkout
fatman20 it also comes with a copy of
the man's
the [ __ ] manscape daily news the ball
review
yeah i have not honestly i it's been so
long since i saw a newspaper
i was so delighted by this i was like i
felt like i was in europe with fish and
chips i was like this is positively
continental
it's been a long time since i've seen a
newspaper i remember being a young man
moving out of my house for the first
time i always thought that the height of
being an adult was getting the sunday
new york times
and then like knowing how to fold it and
read it so that you got all right this
is a one above the fold this is the next
story this is a [ __ ] like
origami transformer of information
and so that that brought back some some
good memories you wrestling with the
newspaper
as a kid who uh worked retail mark i
don't know if you know this but i used
to work in this little convenience store
in new jersey i don't really talk about
it nobody knows this part of my life but
i was involved in retail at one point
and um in retail on sunday mornings
when the new york times used to come and
before there was an internet
and the only place we got our news was
either from tv or from reading a
newspaper
the new york times we would let's say
quick stop got 100 copies of the new
york times
you had to put them together and they
were built of separate sections that all
came throughout the week some [ __ ] that
was not going to change
like the arts and leisure section that
came on wednesday with a bunch of other
sections that were immutable
then the last thing that came was on
sunday morning which would be the front
page in the sports and anything that
just happened recently
and so your job was to [ __ ] put the
papers
together man because they were honestly
in four different piles
and they turned into as you well aware
like thick as a dick man just [ __ ]
luscious like the new york times you
could kill a [ __ ] with the old
new york times i don't know what the
sunday new york times like anymore
but back in the day it was the bane of
my existence putting together that
[ __ ] newspaper every week so much so
that i begged my friends come down and
help me i beg walter
flanagan well and brian johnson i said
can you wake up at six in the morning
well really 5
30 and come to quick stop with me and
make the papers and they'd be like
you're out of your [ __ ] mind
the only one who ever said yes was
jason muse oh and jason that was how we
built our friendship
that's how we start watching degrassi
together that's how we became literally
became jay and salam bob sitting there
watching uh tv and making the newspapers
on sunday morning
but i remember i offered him like money
i was like oh you know if you come down
and
make the papers with me on sunday
morning i'll give you two bucks he was
like all right
two dollars bro that's at night that's
in
we're talking 80s money like this ain't
like a story about the [ __ ] 40s and
[ __ ] like that
in 1989 i was like if you wake up at six
in the morning
and stay with me at quick stop until
noon
i'll give you two dollars and it's
almost like
dude don't even offer me money if you
can offer me
well honestly he was doing it not
clearly not for the money and [ __ ]
i mean if anything maybe he was like
look i go there i eat some free food it
works out
but he clearly did it for the
camaraderie and like and here we are
years later we have a
business together so the point of that
story kids is
is that somewhere in jay's house there
is an old coffee can
filled with the two dollars that you
gave him every sunday oh my god that's
the beautiful ending to our life story
movie is that
like i'm i've lost everything and he
gives me
a get like a can coffee can and inside
it's got cash and i'm like what is this
what is this and he's like that's all
the money you ever gave me to come help
you make the papers
and it's like 28 and i'm like this
ain't gonna [ __ ] help
credits
it's like what's the interest on 28 over
35 years like well
like i'm like 28 he's like you only did
it 14
times i saved it just in case that's
that's all of it yeah if you had been
more generous in your youth
you would have more money now so the
lesson here is
[ __ ] two dollars i've been waiting 40
years
to teach you this lesson [ __ ] two
dollars
[Laughter]
people like boy you know i thought i
knew their story but i guess they were
kind of shitty with each other at the
end over
math i don't know
uh it's like the butt abbott lou
costello [ __ ] story
did you ever see i remember this movie
still [ __ ] haunts me
they made a tv movie of the abbott and
costello
like story and [ __ ] and not the good
parts right like it's not like
they were fun and happy and they had
good times it was about like how they
fought and [ __ ] like and [ __ ] bad
sad things that happened i'll never
forget this i think it was
which one hey i bet so lou costello the
short the
the the stockier one i think if i
remember
that movie correctly he had a kid that
like fell into the pool and drowned and
that's why they started putting
fences around pools um but like i had
i remember i watched it was a tv movie
on like cbs or
nbc in like the late 70s early 80s
but it was one of the most terrifying
things i'd ever seen on tv that
moment because that had that was not
part of our world we didn't have
in-ground pools where i came from so
you couldn't fall into an in-ground pool
you know
yes unless you stumbled onto some
millionaires [ __ ] you know estate
nobody was falling into an above-ground
pool you just bump into the wall
a lot so this kid had this was an
in-ground pool
and it was so sad but also so terrifying
because i was
not that young as when the kid fell in
the pool but young enough to be like
that's a thing to worry about now so
there were two things like that i got
from watching tv movies that terrified
well three
one was the falling in the pool like lou
costello's kid
the other was the day after remember
that [ __ ] thing
oh my god when they were like is there
anybody out there anybody at all and
everybody was [ __ ] dead and [ __ ]
but there was no like mad max or
dinosaurs it was just sad
um and then the third one is um
is it don't be afraid of the dark the
one with the whispering little [ __ ]
that live under the
radiator and [ __ ] yeah oh my god
guillermo del toro was involved in a
remake and it was okay but the original
is so [ __ ] 70 scary and you know what
there's a fourth
um it's not a tv movie but a 70s movie
race with the devil
terrifying [ __ ] movie if you're a
catholic kid that's got
peter fonda and warren oates and loretta
swit
i forget who the other lady is and it's
these uh
two couples that go motorbiking
like in the desert or [ __ ] out
somewhere in baja california or whatever
the [ __ ]
and they gotta winnebago and so they're
camping they're going
basically it was just warren warren
oates and peter peter uh
fonda like got paid and they said you
say it says it if you read the history
of the movie
they just got paid because they wanted
to go ride motorbikes in baja so like
we'll do this [ __ ] movie sure
so in the winnebago these cats they go
driving around during the day on their
bikes and then they're having like a
campfire and [ __ ]
and they're in the middle of nowhere and
then they hear something in the distance
and they go through the [ __ ] brush
and they find
like a satanic ritual in progress
so there's like all these satanists and
robes and [ __ ] and then they bring out
like a girl and they take her clothes
off like when i say girl i mean like in
her 20s or whatever
and so you know at first they're like oh
look at this it's an orgy
and then motherfucker's just like and
kills the girl
and like loretta sweat or the other
woman in the couple
is like and screams and all the
satanists [ __ ] turn and they're like
and then they spend the rest of the
movie chasing that [ __ ] winnebago
down but i'll i mean it's terrifying if
you're especially if you're a [ __ ]
catholic when i was a catholic kid
like satanists were like that's as bad
as it [ __ ] got right like on earth
you couldn't be worse than a satanist
so it's terrifying but there's a scene
in the movie where
they don't know what a satanist is you
know they got to do this for the rest of
the audience that don't [ __ ] know and
[ __ ]
so get this they go to a library
[Laughter]
while they're on the run from the
satanists
it's not their winnebago in the library
and they're looking up
facts about satanism and [ __ ] like that
but it's gotta get like 20
of the budget from like the american
library association so it's like listen
we'll give you money for this but you've
got to have a scene in a library
i'm sure the library association was
like finally yes
like we do play a part thank you very
much and it has a terrifying ending
where they get a web spoilers if you i
mean [ __ ] good luck finding this
movie but spoilers
if you're gonna watch it they get away
from the satanists and [ __ ] who are
chasing the whole movie kill their dog
and [ __ ] they're just trying to get to
them
and finally they get to a place where
you're like oh they're we made it and
they're all relieved and they come to a
halt and [ __ ]
uh and stop the winnebago and they're
doing the you know backslapping whoo
we lived and blah blah and then all of a
sudden a [ __ ] ring of fire
lights up around the winnebago and
they're like
no and you pull up and you see like the
satanists have surrounded them with
[ __ ] flames
it is it's [ __ ] intense it's a movie
you could literally remake today would
still [ __ ] work
i thought you were gonna say and then
the satanists go to the library
and get a phone book and discover their
addresses they're like
they're like we they don't know enough
about us we really don't know enough
about motorbikers who go to baja so we
gotta
find out more let's go to the library
there's a whole this sort of knowledge
cuts both ways
yes that movie falls apart with the
advent of the internet right like
you know in the first and the cell phone
like in the first 10 minutes
you see a sacrifice and maybe you're you
know somewhere where your signal's not
up but sooner or later
you're going to be in signal distance
you call a cop you can literally take
[ __ ] pictures video
so like yeah that movie wouldn't i don't
know if that movie works quite the same
way
it does nowadays or is it it's a bummer
anyway and i just have to be
you know like joshua tree or something
where there is no internet and there's
never going to be an internet and it's
like oh [ __ ] we can't call anybody
we it seems like we're back in 1973.
you've just described a much better
horror story right
there with your log line of there is no
internet there's never gonna be an
internet
no you move to the hollywood hills
trust me if you want to fall into that
dead zone be up here but not anymore
[ __ ] because i am
cabled in i'm plucked right the [ __ ]
into the wall man
so as i say it it's not being traveled
through no wise and fires
it goes through a goddamn wire the way
[ __ ] power should
it's good enough for all dad it's good
enough for me
let's um we've probably been talking
about uh
in chat somebody said uh lumpyhippo
hoodies.com says back when the dewey
decimal system could save you from
singing
it's just the 800s no say this to the
300s
in religion that's them picking through
cards
it's that no satan with an a not an eye
um all right let's uh get to what we're
here to talk about
yes sir and that is of course uh
last night or yesterday friday at 12 a.m
uh juan division happened again for
episode
six i've just done a [ __ ] ton of talking
about
race with the devil a subject nobody
came here to hear about
oh except you know there's maybe two
people in the audience who are like
think i remember that movie but can we
talk about wanavision uh let's start
with you and your take on it because i
just freshly watched it
right before this show so i got all
sorts of thoughts i mean i'd seen it
last night
but i also just rewatched it what'd you
think of this week's wine division
um i i am now going to be uh
steadfast the show is fine
but are you being that way because you
feel that way or you just don't want to
catch [ __ ]
um you know a little bit of both you
know
there are times you just i don't need
this in my life
this level of of of antagonism is
pointless
but i i do think you know and i said it
last week i said the week before
the more context we get about what's
happening in the show the more i'm
interested in the show
um i was i was less on board when it was
just
a kind of meta exercise in sitcom
recreation um
and more interested in it once it
becomes what it seems like it's going to
be which is you know
wanda is in some fashion or another
trapped in this place whether or not she
has control over it or not
and episode 6 shows that she has lots of
control over it
um when she expands the borders of west
view
um you know but also not enough control
over the people within it
and the the most harrowing scene i've
seen in a while in one of the
in the show like this is just that woman
who's
like almost putting up her halloween
decorations
but stays in this crazy loop where she
can't actually put it up and then you
like
push it a little bit you see the tear
streaming on her eyes and that
that idea that again everybody's a
prisoner and wanda has but so much
bandwidth
to deal with all of them so when the
focus of the show is on her and her
immediate surroundings it's full of life
and joy and everybody's kind of animated
but for the parts the
of the valley that the sun doesn't shine
it is just
like zombieland of people kind of trying
to break through the
shell of what their former lives used to
be
um and i'm i'm i am now
more invested in the vision story than i
am in the wanda story
because the vision story is tragic to me
the vision story is
here's a guy who thinks he knows exactly
what he is um and who he is and what his
history is
and the longer we are with him the more
he realizes that he is not what he
thought he was
you know when he when he runs into agnes
at the end of town at ellis street which
i also found kind of
nice because warren ellis wrote a book
called next wave
which featured monica rambo as the star
ah
that was the connection when i heard
them when they say alice i was like i
wonder if they mean warren ellis
um i didn't know he worked with the
character before yeah
and it's it's a really fun book it's and
it's worth picking up
um but you know running into agnes who's
like
literally just at a traffic light trying
to find the town square and it's like
you've lived here your entire life how
do you not know where this is
and then he breaks her free of it she's
like oh your vision are the avengers
here and he's like what's an avenger
you know and that sense that he's
beginning to realize that his life is
not what he thought it was that he knows
there are blank holes in his memory
in the last episode episode five when he
started freaking out and he's like i
don't know
you know my life before westview and i'm
scared like the idea of like
nothing you realize like so you're
coming to he's like uh
the character in the classic sci-fi that
is becoming
a war he's he's neo man he's realizing
that he's in a [ __ ] matrix
and like you know he's got to take a
pill and get up to some degree
yeah and so the
the commercial which was the first time
we didn't see
the two the actor and the actress who
have been in every other commercial spot
um as we talked about last week the
commercial seemed to correspond
to the infinity stones that would mean
last uh the eps episode six the yo magic
uh was probably the soul stone um
what would what did you take from it my
take from it was
here's a little kid who's starving and
we'll
i'll i'll eat anything he says or
whatever and the shark gives him this
thing that he can't
then open and then he [ __ ] turns
skeletal and [ __ ] dies
i mean it was like you know it all the
other ones worked as commercials like we
could actually see them selling a
product this one it's just like
who would want to eat this [ __ ] like
especially when the commercial is you
can't [ __ ] open it to the point of
death
but what i took out of it was the little
kid is
her like she's starving
like you know for whatever the
companionship
[ __ ] you know people not to die in
her [ __ ] life
and the shark could represent
somebody who offered her a seemingly
good thing which we now see isn't very
nourishing
at all and so last week of the week
before i was
like there's no way it could be mephisto
why would they just suddenly mephisto us
nobody doesn't
people don't know about mephisto that
commercial
and then also the conversation that she
had with pietro
where pietro essentially not even
tacitly
but gave full-throated support
for what she's doing knew exactly what
she was doing and controlling the town
and [ __ ] and gave support to the point
where she's like you don't think this is
bad and he's like no i think it's
amazing and stuff
but the way he was talking to her i'm
not gonna say like it didn't sound like
pietro
but it sounded like the devil so
i'm gonna i'm gonna mend my i don't
think it's mephisto
and be like maybe it is mephisto
i just find that incredible we got three
episodes left right
yeah and and apparently each of those
three episodes according to
and fight he's give me an hour long are
you [ __ ] me so next week's episode
is an hour
yes the last each of the last three is
going to be an hour long let us all pray
the great god feige who not only given
us like
six episodes of a wonderful show but
then he's giving us three hour longs of
that show
what do we do to deserve this guy [ __ ]
he's the goods in any event
um i feel like it could be mephisto but
don't you find that
odd that they would just like think
about
how long they built up to thanos
but then again in a movie you only have
two hours and they're like here here's
dormammu
and you know we got the concept within
two hours and bang
so i guess it wouldn't be like out of
the ordinary unheard of
if one division was indeed a two-hour
movie
and they introduced mephisto we i
wouldn't think twice i'd be like well
that's what they do
but it just felt like this was so
protracted and
also like the character at first i was
like well mephisto needs a lot of
[ __ ] like
you know laying to the seats and then
you're like not at all he's the devil
he's literally
one of the oldest figures in any
storytelling medium or mode there is
this one just has a different [ __ ]
name which is actually short from
mephistopheles so that name's been
around forever
so it could very well be
mephisto which like hats off as a guy
who wrote mephisto
for daredevil like i never thought we'd
see [ __ ] mephisto in something
so if it is i think that's [ __ ]
awesome and for the first time
i'm starting to understand that like i
guess it could be
i definitely think that ain't pietro for
damn skippy
um now somebody said online that there's
like
it can't be mephisto because they got to
sell this show in china
and china don't like the devil or
something like that this is first i
heard of this [ __ ] i don't know
so that means he could be you know take
it down a notch
and you could make him nightmare instead
of
mephisto and maybe they're holding with
fisto for something bigger or whatever
the [ __ ]
uh but either way clearly she has been
based on that yo magic commercial if
we're to infer
from those commercials hints and clues
and i think that's the point
i think she entered a deal with the
devil i think somebody offered her
something that seemed like it could
nourish her soul
and clearly isn't nourishing at all
um i mean i think there's there's also
the chance
i mean i don't i don't quite buy the
chinese argument for why this couldn't
be mephisto in the show
because it doesn't they don't have to
sell tickets for it
you know like and then i don't know how
deep disney plus
is in to china i don't assume that it's
much easier
yeah especially with dizzy plus i mean i
can't imagine
and if it's going to be you know the big
bad for phase
four um or whatever phase is the next
phase i can't remember where we are at
this point
um it's possible to shave mephisto so
that he's not actually the devil but he
is
something else maybe he's cosmic maybe
it's whatever maybe
you know in the same way that thor
recast the gods of
of the norse mythology it's just we're
aliens you know you might think we're
gods but we're actually just from
another planet
that maybe mephisto has been interpreted
to be the devil
by some terrestrial religions but he's
actually something older and deeper and
weirder
um because if yeah if they're planning
the big bad for this next phase yes
those will have to eventually play into
china
and risk you know leaving all that money
on the table is not a thing that i think
they want to do
um did you hear um uh
pietro at one point like when he was
with the kids and wanda
he said go on your little hell spawn
yeah
you know i mean now you could just say
oh that's somebody you know
the uncle being sarcastic but like that
seemed like a very
pointed chosen
term yeah uh because i
which made me think because i was
watching it like
she like you know i mean i know it's all
in a [ __ ] bubble that she's creating
but like
even in the real world she probably
would not have been able to make a child
with [ __ ] vision he's a
synthazoid correct made of vibranium so
i don't know a vibranium
so at the end of the day if she does
if if uh those kids what is it wiccan
and um
speed if they are indeed her kids if
they allow those kids to
keep living if they're not just part of
but you know we heard in earlier shows
like no those kids are real and blah
blah
when the and and she's in some sort of
deal with the devil
then he'll spawn meaning like they were
the children of the devil would be
very on point and appropriate
you know and then the other thing is i
guess we could be introducing the fisto
which you know would be cool um
but there's also the i mean somebody had
popped a panel
into uh into some twitter chain was like
i can't wait for this moment
and it's magneto you know kind of
hovering over
the what would have to be the avengers
at least in the comics
demanding that he has his daughter back
right um
you know and so if all of this is going
to be a way to introduce magneto and if
that is the luke skywalker level cameo
that they're referring to by the end of
this show is
fassbender um here demanding his
daughter back
um that's kind of cool i would take that
a thousand times over i don't know if
they're setting us up for that though
um uduko vitaman
in the chat said pietro also said the
town was quote charming as hell
and once again like hell um
maurice suggs in the chat said i think
the kid not being able to open the old
magic is the twins not being able to
unlock their ex gene powers without the
shark
hydra and nightmare like ajax unlock
deadpool's powers
i think that's a stretch like god bless
but i think my interpretation is
more on point i think it was odd that it
was a boy character though
if it was meant to be wanda or whatever
but man that's like a deep cuts read
well done worries
um let me uh
well what the what uh
oh i was i thought this was one division
because i was like what the [ __ ]
jay-z just deleted i went to read a
[ __ ] uh
comment and it literally disappeared in
front of my eyes it was somebody denying
covert but i thought it had to do with
wand division so i was like uh
wait i don't know um let's talk about
another aspect of the show um not so
much uh
this episode but definitely last episode
when first she said like i know what an
engineer monica rambo said i know an
engineer would like to take a run at
that
they just talked about building a
special box to get inside
you know and um
do you think she's referring to
some people are saying hank mccoy which
i guess is possible but it feels like
it's reed
richards sue richards or
victor von doom which if they're
starting fantastic four they could start
with
and every week as i look at these sword
costumes
all i see are the fantastic four outfits
like
feels like you're cutting the table
right in front of us no
i mean they could be i feel like that is
a massive leap for them to take
um to to
to use this to launch the fantastic four
you you could
totally but it it just it feels like a
really weird place to do that
um with no context for the fantastic
four within the universe yet
um you know like there's a world where a
tank pim
you know like i need an engineer who's
really good at this [ __ ] like i found
that guy there's a world in which it's
bruce banner but she said it's her like
she
like uh she knew somebody like somebody
in the chat just said
um online they're theorizing that it
could be rocket
would she know rocket from being a
member of sword like prior to what's
going on in the events of juan division
they implicated that she has been to
space
like you know there was like the idea of
every all missions are grounded and
stuff
so i guess that's possible somebody's
saying shuri could be the engineer but
like
how would monica rambo know shuri yeah i
mean i guess there's
there's a lot we don't know about
monica's history you know she literally
went from being you know a
six-year-old muppet to like a grown-ass
woman who clearly had had some
some professional escapades with sword
so and had been to space so like
anything is on the table i suppose
but my gut tells me it's going to be a
person we've seen before
and not a new character we haven't seen
yet um
which is which is why i sort of go the
bruce banner you know hank pym
rocket is also totally cool like there's
the version where yes she and
captain marvel have had adventures in
space
and so yeah there's there's
oh it could be nebula jared babble says
it's her scroll friend from captain
marvel that would make sense too she was
hanging out with a little skrull kid
wasn't she in the movie yeah um
yeah oh i mean this is kind of fun of a
show like this where it's like you know
in
three weeks we'll know all the answers
but right now we're like but it could be
and it could be was um
paul bettany um the show i mean look
both of them are killing it
showing wonderful acting chops once
again elizabeth gets showcased moments
her dealing with
her kids this week was
like it caused my wife jen to be like is
she does she have children
and i was like i don't think so she
maybe she's married but i don't think
she's got kids i was like she's not like
an instagram person so i don't know
anything about her really
she goes well if she doesn't have kids
that's a really good performance because
that
sounded exactly like a parent when she
was like look at me in focus she was
like that was
so after she [ __ ] zapped pietro
across the [ __ ] square when he was
like
you know your dead husband can't die
again and she [ __ ] boom hit him with
some hex magic and [ __ ]
and then she turns the kid and she's
like focused and the kids are staring at
what she just did
um she had a really intense moment and
also i loved it when she like stopped
the town and then [ __ ] you know grew
the walls and [ __ ]
but paul bettany had this really [ __ ]
sweet subtle moment right at the top of
the show when he first came down in the
outfit
and she complimented him in the outfit
and he said like
just so shitty he was just like well it
was the only thing in my closet
he looks at him and then he's like you
charming no good you know and then
turned it on and [ __ ]
but for that moment you saw clarity
like he's clearly he's trying to get
get out as we saw in this episode as he
went looking as he talked to agnes
i don't know if i buy the agnes thing as
like she's
been zapped out of it or something like
that that might have been
she's been too prominent a character to
just be
you know [ __ ]
controlled like everybody else or maybe
i'm wrong like like i said i thought
mephisto wasn't in
so at that point vision goes for the
wall and walks through
and what i took out of that is as he got
out into reality
what happened to him in reality comes
back
so he was just blown up and destroyed
and they showed him disintegrating
but when they last showed him he was in
pieces right
so my assumption is he would eventually
revert
back to what he looked like before they
got him either way
he was [ __ ] dying and paul bettany
had a really great moment there
too where he was like help
and which at first you never hear a hero
[ __ ] say help and that was just
harrowing in and of itself uh but then
they cut to darcy and they come back to
him and he goes help
the people and i love that because if
that ain't [ __ ] superheroes
what the [ __ ] is the dude is living
literally falling apart and
dying reality taking him out piece by
piece
and he's still [ __ ] trying to help
others and [ __ ]
i absolutely love that [ __ ] moment
but it was so dope
when she was like focused you got to
tell me where he is and wiccan was like
i see soldiers and [ __ ] like that and
then
she just like stopped and [ __ ]
expanded the walls
turning a sword into the circus was like
brilliant turning them all into clowns
it was real stroke of brilliance as well
she's now expanded the parameters of
west view
which means she could probably keep
going and
expand it to the world and you know
there there goes your
avengers level threat right there i mean
she's
no longer localized we've seen and as
you saw from the outside it was
hexagonal shape that had like real
corners to it and [ __ ] like that
um so i think he did i think paul
bettany
had some nice moments to work with this
week and last week and stuff
but i'm still way more invested in
wanda's story i love it especially like
this week where she talked to her
brother
about being like alone she was
describing depression
and she got there and she was just like
and who can't [ __ ] like
there are a lot of people who can really
straight up identify with that
but who can't identify with like getting
the blues and some people [ __ ] really
like uh it's go this beyond the blues
it's [ __ ] clinical and [ __ ]
and the lead of our show is essentially
exemplifying that you know like it's
to me it's incredibly [ __ ] engrossing
uh
her sad story keeps me [ __ ] coming
back and watching her try to like keep
up the joy as things are now slowly
unraveling
you know has been the height of drama
for me that's definitely the show
that i showed up to watch for sure back
to you
um no i i i see all of that and i think
that
you know the deeper we get into the show
and the more these things the more the
drama actually gets to be on the surface
the more invested i am in it um i'm i'm
less
i'm less actively invested in wanda only
because it's still
wanda as the bad guy for vision trying
to figure out his life
is a little bit more tactile a want than
wanda struggling to contain this thing
with no real antagonist at play you know
she's her own antagonist which is like
interesting from a cerebral kind of
point of view but it's hard to dramatize
and she's doing
a lot of work and a lot of it's very
strong and
i think the further we get into it the
more that conflict becomes clear
um but i'm just i'm still a little bit
more you know
i'm on the side of the prisoner trying
to escape then the
warden trying to keep the prison
together um
a lot of people a lot of people in chat
mark are pointing out that the
wall extension could keep going all the
way to red bank new jersey and
engulf jane salab's secret stash
something tells me if that happened
nothing would change
we're all still clowns at the end of the
day
her powers are have nothing on
jay jane sambab um secret stash
ability to remain very trapped in time
like can't take it out of there um
it was uh the kids uh i'll be honest
with you my way into this episode
wasn't as fluid and clear as the last
episode because
i was not a big malcolm in the middle
guy
and i realized it was because at this
point in this decade of sitcoms
like by 94 i was like making clerks and
and it was like sundance and [ __ ]
so i was making stuff prior to that
i lived through like all of the sitcoms
that they
had presented or watched them on like
[ __ ] reruns or something
so when they started as malcolm in the
middle i was like
oh well i guess that makes sense but i
didn't have the same emotional
connection to it that i had to say
the family ties opening that they did
last week what about you
yeah similar you know like the the
dennis the menace style precocious kid
sitcom was never my favorite
mode of sitcom so i was like oh okay i
see what you're doing
i don't care that much but i see what
you're doing and it's always
a spot-on recreation of the mood of
those kinds of shows everyone in the
chat is going like malcolm in the middle
was 2000
yeah i know but
well i mean i i don't did they do the
90s
you know i mean
was a mixture of the 80s and 90s i mean
i know it was like family ties but they
also had
i don't know i guess yeah somebody's
saying
mike is saying in chap that modern
family is next wouldn't that be the
2000s or is that the 210s
that's the 2010s i think because i know
that there was footage of her talking
directly to camera
yeah um really malcolm in the middle
started in the 90s i'm not [ __ ] crazy
weren't they doing malcolm in the middle
very much it's like knock him in the
middle a little bit of parker lewis
can't lose
a little bit of like doogie howser that
kind of like video confessional
you know first person to the screen kind
of thing
um weird that they didn't do seinfeld
i mean i guess that's not a family
sitcom right
uh and somebody anthony prone saying
kevin you miss out malcolm was terrific
show
be funny if married with children was
next married with children would have
been the 80s
because that's when that [ __ ] started i
was there for it i watched that
[ __ ] day it was like it was it was
mad with the children
and the simpsons and cosby and clearly
they're not doing cosby
but those were all on kind of at the
same time so that means that like
if they're doing modern family next then
there might be the office
with that [ __ ] rack focusy [ __ ] and
whatnot like that would be
would that be the 2000s or the 2010.
although the office
is before modern family yeah
you're right and then and the office is
not a family sitcom so maybe they don't
touch that right but the documentary
style like we're going to sit down and
do interviews of people
you know giving confessionals did they
do that i've never watched modern family
do they do that on modern family
camera yeah you know and sometimes i
have
you know clusters of characters like
we're all being interviewed and it's
you know mom and dad and there's grandpa
and whatever and
william seek said the intro was real
world from the early 2000s that intro
was malcolm
in the middle no yeah like it looked
like am i crazy what am i i'm like these
people got me thinking i'm high
and i am but like
you don't remember i thought aren't we
all in agreement malcolm in the middle
trended the night that the episode
dropped and not because we all
suddenly remembered it because of the
opening credits of the show it's always
interesting to see like what people see
and what you see and what other people
[ __ ] see
nuts um yeah no i thought it was a good
episode you know
i i i am not wasn't as good and this
isn't a knock but it
i wasn't as uh like into it as i was the
previous week episode
and i like that wanda showed her powers
and [ __ ] [ __ ] with the outside
world
but it was way better for me personally
when she went out and [ __ ] confronted
them
and was like you know talking to him and
[ __ ] like that so by virtue of like if
somebody was like you're going to a
desert island you could pick only one
episode
five or six i would definitely pick five
uh but six had some good stuff in it
you know like i i am no longer in the
i wish i'd never watched this show or i
could have abandoned it at episode two
which i felt in episode two
um i mean and we all [ __ ] knew that i
was gonna watch all of it i knew i was
gonna watch all of it
um but i i am not i'm not in love with
the show
but i like it you know and i'm hoping by
the end of it the payoff is strong
enough to eventually shift into love
dre bautista said something here that
made me go holy [ __ ]
dr strange sent quicksilver at the talk
he didn't say i am your brother
um i could be all this time maybe it's
doctor strange
sending somebody else and i forgot he's
showing up so it could be him
somebody [ __ ] tweeted something
and it was such a strong tweet that i
took a screenshot
i'm gonna find it and read it to you
because it really [ __ ] blew my mind
but i was like
uh and i hope they're right because i
was like if this is it man
that is so [ __ ] cool um
i'm trying to find it because i want to
give this cat
their [ __ ] proper due it is
um is it him yes
andrew pooley andrew
pooley p-o-o-l-e-y-11
on twitter he wrote to both of us and
andrew said ready for this
i have a theory for you guys what if all
the people who were snapped
or blipped came back as mutants
that's a way to do it bro it's it's
definitely a way to do it
although that's a lot of [ __ ] mutants
including lots of people you've already
seen before but
probably not it but what a great theory
i would have liked that guy in my
writer's room i would have said you
jeff's kiss
and they would have said who's right but
i like where your brain's going
jeff is one of my friends jeff's kiss
i'll give it to you
um yeah uh you know they did the blood
test with monica rambo and revealed that
her
she's being changed at a molecular level
so that means they're setting her up for
what photon
or essentially captain marvel herself
because she eventually does become
captain marvel
um but some people are like oh my god
she's a mutant
that's not what a mutant is mutant is
born at least according to marvel comics
a mutant
is born with a genetic abnormality that
makes them special or gives them an
ability
a mutate is somebody like
you know [ __ ] uh uh matt murdock
peter parker uh
grim things that science have happened
to
that have changed them and given them
powers but they were not born with that
ability
so technically speaking if we were you
know i mean they could do whatever they
want in the marvel cinematic universe
but technically speaking monaco rambo
can't be a mutant she would be a mutate
so if anything perhaps
you know what they're going to tell us
is that there have always been mutants
and that just like [ __ ] with the mind
stone
released her mutant powers
and her brother's mutant powers maybe
whatev maybe this [ __ ] that she's doing
is going to do the same thing where
it'll awaken people who have these
latent mutant powers like so maybe that
mutants have been with us all along
but you know in a reverse of house of m
she's just going to be like more mutants
and
snap everybody's [ __ ] everybody who
has a mutant gene goes on and then they
become mutants
because you're right it couldn't be half
the world right
um that would be way too too many
mutants then you get to that [ __ ]
house of m storyline quick where it's
like no more mutants
i mean off of that the idea that
everybody who
is within the boundaries of west view
has had their molecular structure
already affected i'll take that bro
because that means every mutant's from
new jersey
[Laughter]
i get so proud whenever they say new
jersey on the show i look at my wife
where i'm like as if i had something to
do with it where i'm like
where does he represent um
what else to say about the show anything
other than [ __ ] i was mad when it was
over but you just made me so happy by
saying the next three episodes were like
an hour a pop [ __ ] man
i keep watching the credits hoping that
there will be something at the end of
them
because are like 19 minutes long
and i keep hoping that some of those
minutes is like content it never
is never is uh
this guy mg said on chat
hayward is building sentinels i've seen
that expressed a few times
on uh online people are saying remember
they walk through that big hanger with
the high ceilings and [ __ ]
somebody's like he's probably building
sentinels that would be [ __ ] badass
i keep wanting monica rambo to just
punch him in the face when he was like
i'm so glad your mother's dead
because she would hate what you become
it's like oh this [ __ ] needs
some
i keep thinking too he's like too
[ __ ]
bad to be a bad guy you know what i'm
saying like
i feel like there's going to be a
shyamalan like twist
where you know he's an [ __ ] but he's
a good guy
because if they make him just the bad
guy it's like oh well
i guess yeah that made sense he was
always kind of a bad guy
right i mean unless he's a skrull and
this is also setting up secret invasion
see i was going to compare him to peter
coyote and [ __ ] e.t maybe he's
neutral
i like your [ __ ] scroll thing much
better man yeah
a bad scroll that's grow
uh kevin in chat which i guess is my
conscience asks what is jc's opinion
shall we get jc's opinion on all this
sure what's the man think i don't know
and what opinion is he looking for
exactly um
darcy just went through darcy just went
through the wave what do you think
happens to darcy
she can pick up the hammer now i think
that i thought it was the
changing the dna i thought was an
interesting touch that they specifically
called that out um but it would be weird
if all mutants were from west view new
jersey i think
says you
don't they have their own island like
jenosha or some [ __ ] [ __ ] like
they're already like grouped into a
place why not be new jersey
the um the two things amazing my home
state dude don't take that from
us i lived uh i lived in hoboken for a
few years
i've got a little jersey in me then you
should be rooting for this you should
back up
uh the two things that stuck out to me
were uh
the incredibles and the parent trap were
on the movie
the incredibles because you know edie
dash
um and uh his sister has weird powers
that's what i figured and parent trap i
figured because
there were two um pietros
somebody uh somebody in the chat
mentioned is incredibles
a fantastic four reference a very subtle
fantastic four reference thank god we do
this show
because yes it absolutely could be a
[ __ ] subtle fantastic four reference
um and then the other thing i really
enjoyed was i believe
when pietro took the kids out
trick-or-treating wanda is like why
doesn't he look familiar hmm
kick ass and i loved that they called
out kick-ass
as having two patros in it yeah
yeah that was cute when she said it i
was like ah
there it is i understand that reference
um you think it's mephisto jc
i don't know much about mephisto but uh
based on
yeah based on what everybody's saying i
think uh
i think it the internet makes a strong
case for mephisto
uh jay david murphy said i said captain
america screwed up taking the stone back
that would be interesting too
if it had something to do with that uh
new jersey
i just saw somebody they didn't say it
in point blank language but they said
new jersey is the home of the new jersey
devil so
it could be that not the new jersey
devil but like
maybe that was a subtle hint
all along new jersey was a and our bad
guy
is the new jer not the new jersey devil
but
uh
um continues to be
one of the most fascinating uh watchable
shows on on tv they're doing such a
fantastic job
uh shall we leave juan division for now
indeed my friend uh
i'm seeing if anybody in chat's got any
final interesting thoughts
they're so helpful in the conversation
because sometimes they remember [ __ ] we
don't talk about
uh neil parker says uh
hayward and shield will make ultron
be a part of the sentinels with vision
tied into it
then giving the mutant story well
hayward seems very interested in getting
pieces of uh
of uh you know
uh vision back like he wants
they had the synthezoid body and you
know clearly they're the weapons
division now so they want to
weaponize them in some way
there's there's a bit where i was a
little confused and by confused i just
mean that it's a mystery that they
haven't paid off yet
where hayward starts talking about an
asset they have inside the town
yeah do you think that asset is
pietro and i wonder if there's a version
of pietro who's not at all
pietro but who might be like taskmaster
or something like somebody who can
mirror the the powers of
quicksilver but isn't and so her testing
him and him not passing the test but
deflate deflecting the test
do you remember when we were kids and
our mothers and blah blah he's like
you're testing me i see you you can
trust me i'm your brother
yeah could be doctor strange but it is
more like the devil
i don't know why but a lot of people
online reference wonder man
but i'm like i i can't see them doing it
this way but who knows
um dottie has been missing for a while
um and we you know we see the
townspeople
all the time so there feels
like there's something there the fact
that
we don't see dottie anymore but we were
told that
like in that episode well dottie's in
you know charge of everything or
whatever the [ __ ]
so i feel like emma caulfield who we're
you know [ __ ] almost had on the show
and then
we we've been playing phone tag with or
whatever
um i feel like you know there may be
more
to that storyline than they've let on
you
you have three more episodes i i i do
think that there is
um to your point why set up a character
that big
and never come back to her again
uh there's a lot of uh people in chat
saying that uh info leaked and i'm not
gonna share that info in case
it's right or if anyone knows it um
but uh if it is that would be amazing
and you know remember we all heard about
evan peters because of a leak
um so
i guess jeff's kiss to the
potential leak rumor if it's true if
it's the case
it's what it's gonna make everybody
happy and everybody's gonna
[ __ ] win emmys do you think they do
another one of these yeah dan
dre batista points out he never said i'm
your brother
uh smg says dottie is another sorceress
who along with agnes
helped whomever mephisto set up this
rosemary's baby situation
that's what it is kind of a rosemary's
baby situation like they wanted her
to have these [ __ ] kids so that they
could steal those kids like which is
kind of what they did in the comics
right
and ultron still hasn't shown up yet i
think that's kind of weird
why are strawberries a massive clue
somebody said strawberries are a massive
clue it's totally agnes's husband ralph
dude is mephisto go back and watch how
agnes talks about ralph
yeah there are times when she does she
references ralph where you're like oh
maybe he's uh simon williams says
dottie equals pietro equals mephisto
um that's true mephisto could be wearing
many faces throughout the show
i saw this great meme which was like you
know this dude
with a butterfly landing on his finger
and it was like the dude was marvel fans
and the butterfly
was just like is this mephisto like
anybody could be mephisto
like is this character is this character
how about them all being a fist
um who was eric birch said what's the
leak rumor
it is uh regarding the uh
luke skywalker level cameo um
yes which i don't want to know and i
don't know why people want to know
yeah and truly especially you're this
dependent there's only three episodes
left and three episodes of an hour a
piece
what happens to darcy do you think her
dna gets rewritten does she become
somebody
um i don't think so i mean she's not
inside the bounds
but she was at the end the wall hit her
and it went through and we didn't see
what happened to her like we saw the
wall
hit sword people and they became clowns
but we didn't see what happened to darcy
yeah i mean i think if you're going to
play fair with those rules then
if everybody in there that happens to
him then it's gonna happen her
but you know if it's a low-level you
know
pass-through i think the the fear was
that
you know monica has gone through twice
already
um and then the third time might be
irrevocable
and so if darcy's inside and she just
passed through once maybe that's not
enough to do
crazy amounts of dna re-scrambling
um somebody said duramamu but it can't
be dr strange
and duramamu made a deal but he would
never come back to
our world yeah people are like what are
you
[ __ ] dumb he's like an
interdimensional demon you think he's
gonna honor his word yeah man otherwise
[ __ ] doctor strange
trap him in a time loop man he brought
time with him and do her mama was like
no
totally [ __ ] i feel like we've gotten
to the point of theorizing where people
are just
like i know a name and then that's the
name
what a fit store mama sure
um frost giant once again
we've got a painful [ __ ] six day wait
until the next episode
indeed might have to watch something
else
yeah i don't remember watching anything
else this week
i was there waiting for that [ __ ] the
whole time i caught up on the stand
did you watch the whole thing is it done
um it's done
i'm two episodes from the end i watched
the first two
yeah it's uh it's not great
is that right first two i like i
i was like all right but i just i
haven't gone back to it it didn't
like it wasn't it wasn't like one
division where i'm like get out of my
way
yeah yeah like they they they take some
liberties with the uh the chronology of
the story
they did in the first two episodes alone
where i was like whoa
well well yeah somebody somebody is uh
being a little free with this
king text but then i understand that
king wrote the last episode or wrote a
new ending for it or something
yeah like the the book ends with like
you know
spoilers there the conflict is resolved
between the forces of good and the
forces of evil
and so what and so it's done like the
whole thing is finished
yeah like it's only ever meant to be
just you know it's a mini-series
but king then apparently went in and
wrote like an epilogue
for some of the characters like here's
what happens after the big climactic
battle is is over
um yeah like there's just
it's it take it makes decisions that
kind of
are a little bit mystifying the first of
which is is monkeying with the narrative
like it's a very clean throw from let's
tell the story of how this disease
breaks out to the effects of this
disease to
here's the new world these people start
to build and the first like four
episodes
start just like you know tarantino's
for kind of no good reason it doesn't it
doesn't amplify the experience at all it
just makes it a little bit more
confusing
and then you know towards the tail end
of it you know the the the most recent
episode that i saw
um introduces trashcan man
who in the in the book and in the first
mini series the mcgarris mini series was
played by matt frewer
you know it's sort of this like
pyromaniac character who's also kind of
smart but also a little
touched and you know clearly a little
like neuro-atypical
ezra miller now plays trashcan man and
it's
offensive honestly like you know
to both the spirit of the book and to
neuro-atypical people out there like
wait who's playing the part ezra miller
the flash
the flash and he's not good he's not
just the choices that he makes the the
choices the mini series makes
um you know it's it's i'm i'm way more
sensitive to these things than i
used to be um but you know playing
somebody who's clearly on the spectrum
and having the book kind of the book
does it but
this miniseries especially does it is
anybody who seems neuroatypical is also
bad um
which feels wrong you know or the very
least is is meant to be a victim
which is also wrong who was the
character that was like
m-o-o-n that's yeah yeah yeah tom i
can't remember his last name
you know who's in the mini series and
like you know is is
played you know sometimes for laughs
definitely kind of the butt
of lots of jokes um does retain
some level of empathy um and i think a
lot of that is that actor doing that
work
but the ezra miller of it all is just
you know
embarrassing um but yeah i mean i'll
watch it all just because i'm curious
and i love the book
but this this definitely seems to be the
inferior adaptation of it
all right um we're clearly done with
wanda vision kids
um but while we're on the subject of
things that we've watched that's not one
division uh mark
have you watched um judas and the black
messiah
no that's tonight's mission wonderful
yeah like oh my god the performances are
[ __ ] sublime
um it's a story that like i didn't know
all the particulars of
but like oh my god it's so well directed
so well acting
acted so well cast um what did i just
watch
you know i finally watched um
[Music]
uh black klansmen
which i'd seen the first 20 minutes of
and then never finished and stuff but i
just finally
watched all the way down another
exquisitely cast and made movie but like
that spike he's always great
but yeah judas and the black messiah is
so worth watching what is on hbo
or yeah hbo max i think i saw we had an
early screener so i got to watch it like
a week or two ago
but it was incredibly [ __ ] well made
um
and who's the how do you what's the
actor's name
the lead daniel daniel so [ __ ] good
yeah is that dude british yeah
you would never know like he's just so
[ __ ] good
and everything he is everything he's in
um but yeah it's definitely worth
checking out
yeah i think if i watched anything else
new this week that
i think that's about it man um
yeah all right so we talked about wanda
kids
uh uh next week we'll talk about more
wanda we've got an hour of it to digest
that'll be amazing then they can take
their time
there's always a point in the show where
i [ __ ] check the time because i'm
like
we must be getting [ __ ] close here
like i want to know
how much longer before the
disappointment comes where it's like oh
man
is that it our episode that's going to
be good
um all right let's talk about
uh the news mark uh is a news man of
course
and uh as an old news man he knows how
to get the [ __ ]
thoughts on the news what about talk
about the david lynch dune commentary
oh the one we should do okay you did one
yeah one week we will
we'll do it right here live on the show
um we'll just watch it you know off
camera and [ __ ] you could sync up with
us
and then we'll [ __ ] wandeeb that [ __ ]
because it might seem as a killing word
it's the strength of the base of the
pillar
[Laughter]
mark always has the deeper cuts lying
um all right [ __ ] deep cuts what do
you got uh collected for the news uh i i
know
hey can i start with the news item sure
please do
jc jump on we're gonna kill two birds
with one stone watch this [ __ ]
all right so in the news kids we finally
got to
a little taste of masters of the
universe this masters universe show
that mattel and netflix keep telling us
is coming and [ __ ]
and you know we've seen no proof of it
whatsoever but i saw a video this week
where one of the jackasses that works on
the show
was waving his hands around like a
muppet and talking about how they scored
the great bear mccreary uh for uh their
composer
and um is it possible jc i know when we
play things from youtube
we always get thrown off but if we play
something from our
own channel we can't imagine they throw
us off can they
uh i don't think so and i also because
you're the only one who has that
music there's no way it's in their
database
of of screw these people up again
i think they have finally found a way to
[ __ ] the algorithm
it's taken us a long time but i think
we're finally going to be able to show
something where we won't get thrown off
while we're showing it i'm so delighted
by that
um do you have it can you show can you
roll that uh let's see
oh mo 2 music review do you want me to
just roll the whole thing do we want to
put it
how do we want it to look i'm going to
the go into like middle that's when the
cue begins and stuff
i just want to grab smoke and facebook
is all [ __ ] up okay
let me yeah so they could for a second
or two
watch this is the opening of the not the
opening the uh
transformation theme that bear mccreary
came up with
for masters of the universe revelation
um i have now
i went to the mix we mixed uh
episodes one two and three so far so we
mixed two and three on thursday
three is mark's episode and it's some
[ __ ] wonderful
wonderful [ __ ] um so i've heard his
scores
for episodes one two three and four
and four is insanely [ __ ] metal uh so
this what you're gonna hear is just the
transformation
uh cue and when i say just meaning like
it's not the whole episode it's just the
moment where
you know prince adam [ __ ] raises his
uh sword and fabulous magical powers
uh are revealed unto him and so uh
uh we we can't show it the the
cartoon yet because netflix is like
you know they're they're very
they know what they're doing at netflix
and the fact that they let us do
this was crazy like that they were like
yeah let's do a video where
we watch you watching the cartoon and
hearing the song that'd be great
um so they allowed us to to to do this
to
you know me what how it happened was i
bear had sent me his cues
and i shot a video reacting to the cue
rather than type to him so he could see
my reaction in real time
and he loved it and then uh [ __ ] he
sent it to
rob over at mattel where i said to drop
and uh rob sent it to teddy our boss at
netflix and and so we were talking about
when to and how to announce bear as
composer
and so teddy goes why don't you do it
with that [ __ ] video
where like you watch it he's like that
was so entertaining and so like it made
me happy and you can't show a cartoon
but
you could literally see the joy on your
face and stuff so
let's do that and so uh we put together
this clip that we dropped on
monday uh we're not gonna watch the
whole thing in the first half of it i
blah blah blah
and [ __ ] but uh we'll pick it up from
right from where the music
kind of kicks in you'll hear chris wood
doing one of the most famous phrases in
pop culture history
saying as prince adam by the power of
grayskull
and then you'll also hear i have the
power
you know as he becomes human and [ __ ] so
uh
jc can we play that yeah i'm gonna
bear with me because i'm gonna start it
and then i'll have to fast forward it so
what about
it's about three minutes it's only like
three minutes or two and a half so if
you want to play the whole thing that's
[ __ ] fine that'll give me more than
enough time to [ __ ] burn this down
okay uh you guys should mute on oh no i
can
i can mute you without i got it okay
here we go
all right the kids here's the taste
speak kevin smith uh
and i got an announcement for you um you
know i've been working for
mattel and netflix making this
masters of the universe revelation
series that's gonna debut on the
streamer
um i am happy pleased
proud ecstatic really to announce
our composer we scored a composer uh and
he's scoring for us ladies and gentlemen
and that composer is none other
than metal maestro himself the great
bear mccreery
ladies and gentlemen that's right the
man who gave us the score to the wagon
dead
battle star galactica remember those
drums agents of shield
outlander he's doing the score for
masters of the universe
revelation he's working on it right now
and he just sent me
the first cue his past his first pass
the very first queue
of our show which is the transformation
sequence
when prince adam holds the power sword
aloft and says the magic words and
fabulous powers are revealed to him
um and he becomes he-man so i'm gonna
listen to it
let's listen to it together man at the
same time
uh what you're gonna hear right at the
top of it before bears music kicks in
is perhaps one of the most famous
phrases in pop culture history
uh spoken by our prince adam slash
he-man himself
uh the great christopher woods so here
we go ladies and gentlemen
uh bear goes into the woods let's see
what he comes out with let's check this
out man
[Music]
by the power of grayskull
oh come on
there man look at it well you can't see
it but listen to it
it is perfect perfect
this is the transformation sequence
right here this is where cringer
uh the sword is turned on cringer and he
becomes battle cat
[Music]
oh
ladies and gentlemen that that's a first
pass by a genius i
like i can't wait
by the power of grayskull man that is
fantastic bear mccreary
is our composer ladies and gentlemen the
show is called masters of the universe
revelation and it'll be out in 2021 on
netflix
come on that's some that [ __ ] was so
metal
it's got smoke in the air and it's
making me cough that's how [ __ ] metal
it was
erin mccreery is doing a wonderful job
that show
is is absolute magic i adore it i can't
wait to share it with you
um they'll tell me when that's gonna
happen soon but oh man
like we're uh we're getting to a place
a very important milestone in our
production
process we're about to hit and i can't
even give you that information because
it spoils too much but it's
uh we're in a very very excellent place
and i've seen the toy designs
they're doing like toys not just he-man
toys but toys literally based on
the powerhouse designs like from our
story
[ __ ] that we wrote is resulting in
[ __ ] new versions of these figures
that is like
um on let's see uh
in the in the chat this is ironic jason
garza said as much as i love the show i
really feel like kev is starting to
focus too much on chat
he gets lost in it i completely disagree
um but i also have other people who are
like why doesn't why don't you look at
chat more
like you can't win a mall
well that'll it all changes up in here
do you have this in the news
favreau leaving the project rangers of
the new republic
when when did that break i don't know
somebody put it in chat a guy named my
house wrote favro leaving the project
rangers of the new republic your
thoughts on
losing the character of cara dune i
assume that cara doon's story is in our
news isn't it
uh that is the first item yes then let's
start the news ladies and gentlemen mark
bernardin
goes out of his goddamn way to bring you
the news so [ __ ] listen up where's my
newspaper
we're doing the news that's what we've
been missing all the time
a prop we could be like [ __ ] carrot
top or something like that
he works vegas he sells out vegas this
is
every time we do the new news we gotta
pull out one of these
um all right news man hit us yeah this
week you know
every week it's always like are we gonna
have enough news
to have like a news segment this week
and like hey hey i got something i got
something
what's black and white and heard all
over
mark and kev doing the news man
i can't believe it's taken me the only
like 10 years to come up with that
that's writing right there you just
literally saw writing happen
um all right what's the top story uh it
is
gina carano who will not be returning to
the mandalorian or the star wars galaxy
in any way
following you know a series of
posts it's not an isolated occurrence um
just her most recent was
sort of comparing life as a republican
to say being jewish during the holocaust
um well i mean for the last
post she did yes that was that was the
most recent one
yeah and and like by saying like well
she compared being republican to being
jewish in the holocaust was
like almost like well what was her
theory mark but like when you saw the
actual post it was kind of
bracing i remember reading it when it
went up because like
before it entered deep into the news
cycle
i was reading the news when it first
popped in
and i read it and i was like man like
[ __ ] you're not afraid of getting
fired like it's one
whether these are the things she
believes and feels this
completely different but like you got a
job to protect like you can't
you work for a company that sells to
kids like this just seems like
i know a lot of people are like this is
censorship or
[ __ ] they're going after
conservatives but hey man
like i worked for disney at one point
[ __ ] around and find out you know like
they don't give a [ __ ] about you
at the end of the day if you cost them
one [ __ ] dollar
oh my god you're a persona non [ __ ]
grotta and that was for me when i was
just an
adjunct because of like miramax because
in disney owned miramax at one point
you're like when you're the star upfront
you know character
of like one of their most popular shows
uh like you're you can say anything you
want in this world but you cannot
expect to stay employed by a children's
television company
if you're gonna say some [ __ ] that like
makes their shareholders like upset that
i'm and this is not me saying she should
be and blah blah blah
this is just me going like are you
kidding me of course like look what
happened to
james gunn james gunn wrote some lord
tweets back in the day
they [ __ ] fired him for like two
years so much so that he had to go to
[ __ ] warner brothers
you know and get a suicide squad job and
then marvel came back and said
all right well maybe we went too far or
whatever the [ __ ] but like
these cats are disney they don't [ __ ]
around man like
[ __ ] they're they're there to sell
coca-cola
[ __ ] you know churros you know
not anymore but [ __ ] they're in the
business of selling [ __ ] to you and your
family and your kids
and they don't want to hear a [ __ ]
thing about
controversy so you know this this to me
was like well i guess
of course that's that's what's going to
happen yeah
it is it is somewhat of a of a
no-brainer and and again
it is i've also heard people saying it's
like well you know this
this never happens when somebody in the
far left says something awful it's like
well you know what the far left
never summons nazis like
never the holocaust is never a thing the
far left is bringing up in any way to
compare to anybody
but wait so is the argument that nobody
from the far left has ever lost their
job for saying some [ __ ] on a show
um apparently i mean do we want i don't
want to do this deep
dive but i'm sure you could [ __ ] come
up with examples and whatnot
yeah that's not the point like it's not
the point the point is like when you're
an employee of a company
that company has a conduct policy almost
everyone does and if you violate that
conduct policy then you find yourself on
the on the bleeding edge of
having a job of having had a job and
that's kind of where gina corrano found
herself um
and it's also great batista check those
disney wanted so much a strong woman
that would bow to no one and they got
one well this
well that's they wanted a strong woman
character
like they wrote yeah which they did they
wrote and
um like you know that's what they wanted
they didn't want
a strong woman who would then just say
things that
would make them lose sales and [ __ ] like
that um and again
this ain't me like people are like kev's
a shill now number one
i think i've always been a chill because
i [ __ ] like love to talk about the
things i love to talk about
a shill though kids gets paid to do it
so if i'm a shill
i'm a bad chill because i [ __ ] suck
wanda visions giant [ __ ]
like right in front of everybody like
i'm [ __ ] eating carvel
ice cream every week and i don't get a
[ __ ] dime
i don't even get offered jobs so like
i'm not a shill
i'm just a fan of things and i'm a fan
of the mandalorian and i have no problem
with uh uh is her name's not cara dune
is it that's her character's name yeah
gina carrano you know carano i had no
problem with her and i liked her
character in the show but like this
ain't
up to me i didn't [ __ ] fire her but i
damn skippy understand
that if you work for the [ __ ] mickey
mouse like you're gonna get in trouble
i mean maybe thank god nobody [ __ ]
remembers this but like
i worked for [ __ ] disney way back in
the day when we did the clerks cartoon
and i said some [ __ ] after the show got
cancelled that got me quote unquote
cancelled at the [ __ ] company
like forever so i you know they're they
they run a tight [ __ ] ship over there
you know i'm just i'm not saying good
for them i'm just saying like
everybody knows that like could have
seen this coming man
yeah like anybody who's ever held a job
knows that there's certain things that
you can and cannot do and or say when
working
in that job especially if that job
involves you being a public person
um you know and and i think that people
might be surprised to learn but probably
shouldn't
that yes hollywood as a as a
quote-unquote institution
tends to lean liberal but you know who's
at the top of these corporations
really really really [ __ ] rich white
guys
and you know what really really really
rich white guys are conservative
like kind of all of them are but they
understand
they've got to sell to it to an audience
and the disney audience
just doesn't want to think about this
you know and it's not just
this particular tweet because if you
read the wording of the press release
very carefully
it says gina chrono is not currently
employed by lucasfilm and there are no
plans for her to be in the future
meaning they didn't just fire her she
already didn't have a job
meaning this so
your read on that if i'm understand this
correctly if i'm to understand this
correctly is
we just found out that she doesn't have
a job anymore
but this probably happened a red hot
minute ago
yes according to variety they say
according to sources lucasfilm planned
to unveil karana with the star of her
own disney plus series during a
december investors day presentation but
scrapped those plans following her
november tweets
which were about mocking mask wearing
uh amid the novel you know corona corona
virus pandemic
and falsely suggesting voter fraud
occurred during the election
like they had kind of already put her on
ice
and decided you are not actually going
to be the star of ranges of the new
republic
you might be kind of done and you know
this also might speak to like if she's
in mandalorian season three
at all well they might already know they
said yeah they said no they said there
was
i read something somewhere where she was
there was no season three mandalorian no
plans for her to be in season three of
the mandalorian
right prior to this or whatever oh
that's interesting so
this didn't happen 10 minutes ago this
happened
last year we're just finding out about
it now yeah i think i think this right
now is the answer to the
fire gina carano because as far as the
audience knows
she's still tied to star wars and they
have decided to make it clear
no she's not and also hasn't been for a
while
problem here mark is that in chat people
are getting kind of shitty because this
they read this as a political
conversation we're not
i don't think we're being political
about this at all we're just [ __ ]
telling you the news and [ __ ] like that
uh but i figure i bring a cute dog into
it to calm things down
you know it is it is to your point not a
political conversation
it is you know if you violate a
company's
you know standards and practices and
codes of conduct their repercussions for
that
um you know the there is a hundred
percent
freedom of speech in this country i just
think a lot of people don't understand
what that freedom of speech is
which means the government cannot censor
what you say
and the government cannot censor the
news or organizations that may or may
not decide to reprint what you say
but in no reason guarantees you freedom
from repercussions for what you do say
and that's not a governmental thing this
is a this is a company thing this is a
corporate thing this is a
you just think whatever you want to
think just keep it to yourself
one thing i did see i want to put this
dog down but i really feel like she's
lightening the mood and i also i know i
can't put her down
because i'm sure the joss whedon story
is next
it's a tough week for the [ __ ] news
i'll be honest with you
um but here's my question there you go
um what were we just talking about i was
distracted by the adorable
yes freedom from repercussions um
yeah uh i mean i i'm
the the i don't know there's really
nothing much to say
um it's it's uh
weird that we're only like
finding out about it now i guess it's
not weird if anything they would have
loved to have quietly
just gotten to the next season and
have people be like what happened to
cara dunn and like dealt with it then
but like you know now they're
now they're answering uh questions that
was the thing i was gonna say so did you
see the thing i saw online that was
trending for like a minute
was uh cancel disney plus
how many people mark
do you think seriously would cancel
disney plus over this
like and that that's not me being
political that's not a [ __ ]
blue state redstone whatever i'm just
serious like in the middle of wanda
vision
who the [ __ ] is like you know they they
gotta have your
they gotta be dangling your child over a
cliff
in order for you to be like you know
what cancel
disney plus because they got us right
now
[ __ ] they got us they got us right
after wanda vision you see that [ __ ]
falcon in the winter soldier trailer
that i'm sure we won't be able to watch
or else we'll be throwing off the
internet
like and then after that they'll get us
with another [ __ ] thing and then the
mandalorians back like
you ain't going nowhere man like i saw
cancel dizzy plus i'm like
yeah right i felt like like and do the
right thing
where they're like you know bugging out
trying to get people to cancel [ __ ]
sal
and he's like as good as that pizza is
like no way
um yeah it's uh it was uh
one of the big news stories this week
but we should probably move on before
people
you know i i will just say that i'm
pretty sure like on page three of the
journal of the wills
it says don't start none won't be
none i mean i'm telling you on page one
walt disney the first thing that he ever
wrote a lot of people think it's
steamboat willie
with udi works and stuff no way it was
the book of disney and the first line
literally says and we still [ __ ]
share it today i think it's put on a
wall
in disneyland stenciled on a wall [ __ ]
around
find out it's that simple
talk [ __ ] get hit don't start none
there won't be none it really like comes
down to it and stuff but you can't
you can't work for a company like that
and like say whatever you want and
that's not censorship they're like hey
you want to go say whatever you want
great you just can't [ __ ] work here
yeah that's not censorship that's not
against the law that's having a boss
like my boss [ __ ] long johns when i
was a bus boy in 1984
had the same [ __ ] control over my
life at least while i was in the
building
so it's like when some when you work for
somebody you you don't get to say
everything you want to say you know when
i worked for the la times
yeah it was it was literally part of the
employee conduct handbook
that you cannot tweet about politics at
all
because you know it can be misconstrued
that a employee of the times position
is somehow also the la times position
and they're like
you can't like it's a fireable offense
don't do
it at all and like okay i get it so for
the year that i work for you guys
i'm not tweeting about this stuff
because that was a very very clear
thing you put forward and said is not on
the table
this is not gina's first offense in this
regard
she'd been warned multiple times hey
just maybe slow down
he's back think about it before you
tweet it
and and she refused to do that
um you know how you get around [ __ ] like
this don't work for anybody
like i'm not saying i can say whatever i
want cause i'm [ __ ] married
and uh and i got conscience but
you know i i don't have an employer that
i'm like you know
i got to worry about however if you know
i hope to pick up
side gigs of somebody being like hey you
want to do a voiceover for this
commercial
or hey you want to [ __ ] come do
masters of the universe or something
like that when i'm working for some
other corporate structure you think i'm
gonna go out there in the world and be
like here's what
well number one i never i'm not
controversial in the least my
controversial opinions are [ __ ] like i
don't think it is mephisto
there you know but generally speaking
it's like it's a trade-off you know you
want to [ __ ] be free to say whatever
you want
you just can't have an employer who's
like you know oh we've got a bottom line
to protect
um but yeah this again for anybody in
chat who's like oh this is political
a lot of people keep saying pedro pascal
did something similar
i don't know i didn't hear that um the
the thing that i had heard at least that
that surfaced this week
is that he was i think he's got a
relative
maybe it's a sibling who's trans yes
and and kind of came out of support of
that
person um
which seems personal and doesn't seem
outwardly political it's not necessarily
taking a side it is just
this person who is in my life and i whom
i love i will stand behind
that seems relatively non-controversial
to me
now if you have a position on trans folk
in the lb
gtq community that is not the stance
that he's taking
he's just saying this person's awesome
right
right it's not quite the same as saying
you know because he does not summon
nazis the minute you start talking about
nazis
you're probably on the wrong side of
your corporate relationship
perhaps you're perhaps perhaps you're
absolutely right yeah it's very tough to
unless your like
argument with nazis is like we should
never let that happen again and you're
on the right side of the nazis
um okay all right next up
yeah let's [ __ ] let's get away from
that and have some good old-fashioned
fun man
so that's gotta be the worst story of
the week the most
uncomfortable tiptoe rounded story so
what's the next fun everyone can enjoy
it
um you know story that will just slayer
us mark
yes well the women of the buffy universe
oh another sad story here we go god damn
it
um detail their allegations against
joss whedon um the the sort of the dam
broke
when charisma carpenter who played
cordelia chase on buffy and then angel
um you know put out this very lengthy
post saying that she was inspired by ray
fisher
um to sort of explain what had happened
while she was a an employee of
josh clinton hold on just jumping in
with old school
shinobi clarifies that pedro pascal
compared immigrant children separated
from parents
kept in cages to what happened to the
jews
which old school shinobi says which
isn't wrong yeah that
that's what that's what people were
saying was the moral equivalent or
something like that
i i guess perhaps he did summon nazis
into the equation
but it seems as if the parallels there
were a little bit stronger
i would not have brought nazis into it
that's just me
um anwar wilkerson says it's time to
stop whining about political beliefs
chad
i'm with him all right back to back to
the non-political but equally as [ __ ]
uncomfortable and horrible
joss whedon's story um this all ties
into
you know uh ray fisher who we've spoken
about on a few occasions and just a few
weeks ago we were talking about like
unless
like you know you want to detail what
happened it's getting tougher to
understand what you mean by
inappropriate or whatever but then
charisma carpenter
like co-signed pretty hardcore and she
worked with
whedon on um you'll have to excuse me i
i i'm
this is not me it's you know [ __ ]
what do they call it distancing myself i
just
i'm not the here i'm gonna throw him
under the bus i'm not nearly the buffy
and
firefly fan that mark bernardin is
yes yes in fact i think before the show
was like good luck firefly
fun with the news
um yes i know it must be hard for a
brown coat like yourself today
you know like it it there there is
always
that if you live long enough you will
find that some of your heroes
might not be heroic um and you will find
that some people who make art that you
love
you might not be the kinds of people you
would like to associate yourself with
and we all have to at some point figure
out how to disassociate the art from the
artist
um it's harder and harder because we
learn more and more these days
um you know and especially aided by
people like
charisma oh puppy's back
just gotta keep it sweet while this
horrible shit's gone gotta keep it sweet
but yes
charisma carpenter you know sort of
detailed how you know whedon
abused his power on numerous occasions
instead of buffy and angel
including asking her after learning she
was pregnant if she was going to keep it
um just keep looking at the cute puppy
kids cute puppy
um she said that yes the pregnancy was
incorporated into the show but after she
gave birth
she was fired um i'd heard this story
before before this broke
i don't know where and i'm not saying
like i heard it from
like you know inside sources i think i
read this someplace once yeah she this
isn't the first thing she said she
talked about it at a con
i think yeah yeah she talked about it at
a con and i remember when i read the
story and i'm not like [ __ ]
trying to throw [ __ ] dirt on the
grape but i remember hearing it when i
read the story i was like
you know you can't [ __ ] you know tell
people like you can't have a baby
because we're making a tv show
like that's just yeah you know and then
you can't fire somebody for having had a
baby
um is that what he did that is what she
claims he did
um you know it's it's unclear it's it's
impossible to know the internal
debate that went on about her dismissal
that would require
an investigation and testimony and so on
and so on but
from her perspective and her story is
when she actually gave birth and was
ready to return back to work
the character was killed and she was
fired um
you know and after she reveals all of
that serve sarah michelle gellar
yes and i before we you know what this
is inappropriate but still
it's it has nothing to do with this
topic
um whatsoever this is not an allegation
or an insinuation
but uh i i just gotta throw it out there
because it was good
um anthony perrone says kevin just
pulled out his wiener tonight again
twice twice stick around kids you might
see it a third time if the news gets any
more depressing
all right back to you sarah michelle
gellar who we
know uh very well as tila
in masters of the universe revelation um
she
uh jumped in and and uh said she'd like
as much as she's happy and proud to be
associated with buffy
uh for her whole life for the rest of
her life she doesn't feel the same way
about
whedon is that what it was yeah i don't
want to put words in her mouth her
statement was well i'm proud to have
to have my name associated with buffy
summers i don't want to be forever
associated with the name joss whedon
she's offered her support for everybody
who's sort of coming forward i stand
with all survivors of abuse and i'm
proud of them for speaking out
but she's not making any further
statements on the matter um
um let me jump in with spider mitch on
the [ __ ] chat because
this is interesting to me uh he's he
writes
whoopty do joss whedon what the [ __ ]
don't hire that [ __ ] again
while pricks like david o russell
continue to work after what he did to
lily tomlin on set
and got recorded on camera for evidence
did you ever see that [ __ ] tape
yeah i mean it is like
like that's that's like nuts and
nobody's ever explained they don't have
to explain it i'm not owed an
explanation
but i watch that [ __ ] and i'm like holy
[ __ ] like that's that i just kids just
know that
if you've ever seen that that's not what
it's like
and it never has to be that nobody ever
has to yell at anybody on a set
unless it's like look out the [ __ ]
sentinel is falling on you like to save
your life
but if they're just [ __ ] screaming
because like you know what it's like
it's like when you used to play with
other kids when you were a kid and
there's one [ __ ] screamer who
threw things and was ill-behaved like
don't play with that kid but like
[ __ ]
it never has to be like that um but
that's not that david will russell thing
which as as our
commenter pointed out like there's a
video spider-man pointed out there's a
video you can see the video on youtube
there is no and i'm not this is not me
defending josh but there's no
video of joss tearing people down
although i understand
one of the writers from
firefly this morning like kind of said
yeah no he's i don't know if he was the
one that called him casually cruel or
something like that
yeah i think i think it was jose molina
who did say that like
casually cruel is a perfect way to
describe
that matter and his manner in both the
writer's room and
apparently on set and marty who's gone
on to
other great things and won that but she
was i believe started in buffy
didn't she come out and say something
now as well yeah i mean she she talked
about
you know a supporting everybody who who
is coming forth with their stories but
also saying that
that yes she has you know been witness
to
you know the the the cruel workplace and
has written extensively about how ways
to sort of dismantle
that level of kind of more often than
not
cruel male privilege um that goes on
with showrunners who once
once you're deemed a genius and once you
start making millions and millions and
millions of dollars for a company
that your conduct is is sort of
impenetrable
um and and and has been for a long time
you know much of the industry sort of
cuddled people who were just
you know what you're great and brilliant
you can do whatever you want
adele thomas in chat goes what about if
you if uh you aren't wearing your covet
mask
if i was on a set in fact i've been on a
set yesterday
i went to where's my phone so
this is what i did yesterday mark um i
know there's a better way than holding
up my phone to a screen to do this
but this will be good enough yesterday i
was on set
and i was acting and
does anybody recognize that superhero
if you've got kids you might he that's
me
as a super mega awesome
ultra guy from the storybots
ask the storybot show on netflix the
boys who did jib jab
years ago those little cards you put
your face on a [ __ ] cartoon and [ __ ]
um they sold that company years ago
so that they could make one season of
this show called ask the storybots
which was uh it's it's adorable it's
like a modern-day sesame street
so they sell finance it built this show
and then they licensed it to netflix it
did very well netflix was like we'll pay
for the next two seasons
and they paid for christmas special and
then the boys like were going to be able
to take it out
to someplace else like disney or
universal and netflix was like we want
to buy the whole thing so they bought
[ __ ] storybots and [ __ ] like that
which is awesome so
they they're doing more story bots and
uh they were like uh evan who's one of
the directors and the two brothers
and he was like i when i first saw him
yesterday i was like i can't tell you
the amount of [ __ ] i've done in my life
like i don't care what it is clerks
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] i sold out
carnegie all
[ __ ] sold wrote a new york times
bestseller don't [ __ ] matter
that one little episode five minutes
that i was on
storybox not a week goes by where i
don't get
tweets or [ __ ] instagram comments or
some messages about like
i was watching this [ __ ] show with my
kid and you showed up and [ __ ]
so he goes uh he's going look i know
exactly what you mean he's going between
you and snoop
he's like i see the show constantly in
my [ __ ] twitter feed he's like so
people love super mega awesome ultra guy
he's like would you come back
and do it again i was like [ __ ] yes so
you want to talk about streamlined
production like if you ever watch the
show it looks very [ __ ] expensive
very
high tech beautiful shooting it
it was me red who's doing my hair
makeup well hair makeup because my and
[ __ ] evan who is the director who's
feeding me lines and the guy like
on sound smallest [ __ ] set i've ever
seen
in my life i was like man you guys know
how to keep it [ __ ] tight i thought i
could keep it tight
you guys make an entire kids show
there's nobody here like you know when
they show you behind the scenes on
on sesame street to be fair there's a
lot of puppets and [ __ ] but
there's [ __ ] 25 30 people on the
floor man these cats are making [ __ ]
their kids show there's like two people
guy with a camera and a guy with a
[ __ ] recording sound and [ __ ] so i
was point is i was on a set
in order to go there i had to get a cova
test and advance
uh which i was covering negative then
they said it's a big box of ppe
that you bring with you and [ __ ] masks
[ __ ] face shield
glasses with like [ __ ] drapes like
thermometer hand gloves [ __ ]
sanitizer
like netflix does it right they're like
if you're going if you catch kovac
that's [ __ ] on you
here's everything like so they spend a
lot of money we're seeing budgets
go up now because of covet spending it's
happening right now as we budget clerks
three
having to budget in covid like instantly
brings
the budget up and stuff so netflix sent
the box
i get there to set you ring the director
he let you in
first thing they did with me is they put
me on the phone with the doctor
who was like you know i'm the doctor for
this shoot i just want you to know
everybody
you've come in contact with or come in
contact with have been tested
they're all negative everyone will be
wearing masks and shields
um even when you have to take your mask
off to act
uh if you have any questions uh feel
free to contact me
and then we went about production
so you know everyone was massed up at
one point i had to take my mask off in
order to
be on camera and ship and then when we
were done
we were all leaving and another
production was coming in
and they also probably like us
had you know all their tests and [ __ ] i
would assume
in order but some of them were walking
around without masks and [ __ ]
and at one point we got into it like a
chit chat and i was very
like because they were mask free and i
was like that's going to be the rest of
our lives probably
like where you're just like
hey man that's a little close no
especially without a mask man
but um it's it's it's a lockdown
environment
for shooting ja uh liv you know who
married to josh dr josh rausch
um livy roush working on a flick and and
like she's
like overseeing the kova department and
[ __ ] like that
and she's like the films are set up into
zones so here's a zone
where anybody can be zone a
like that's where the cars come in you
get your [ __ ] checked in blah blah blah
then there's zone b
and nobody from not everyone from zone a
can go into zone b
it gets smaller the circle gets smaller
and then
zone d or whatever the [ __ ] is when
you're on set and that is
absolutely essential personnel only so
someone on camera
someone on sound [ __ ] the actors like
bare minimum and [ __ ]
it's been real interesting to hear about
their process yesterday's though for me
it was just like
two people and stuff but they go out of
their way
to make sure that like you're not gonna
get sick on their dime and their time
they're looking out for people like
and you know i'm sure somebody's like
you're a [ __ ] show for netflix but
credit where credit's due like these
[ __ ] i know they got all the
money in the world but like
not everyone's sending out boxes of
[ __ ] ppe to make sure you're safe if
they're like if you're gonna come work
for us
we're gonna look out for you i was very
impressed by that um but in any event
yeah
[ __ ] it's it's it could be weird out
there
where were we uh
yeah i forgot what we were talking about
too oh joss whedon
uh so yes basically the upshot of it is
is that inspired by ray fisher
all of these women are doing the work
that ray fisher hasn't done
which is detailing here's what happened
to me
while i was working for this man and
here's why it was bad
um which which is always a good thing
the truth is always better than not
truth and
and understanding the totality of
people's experiences
is always important for an empathetic
society to to attempt to go forward
um but like we said before
if rayfish is going to keep flying this
flag he's got to actually put some
[ __ ] words on it
and say this is what happened to me or
say this is why i can't say what
happened to me i'm under
nda's or i'm legally prohibited from
doing or there's an active investigation
i can't say what you know the the litany
of complaints that i have
or violate it if it's that important to
you to get
out if it's that important for you to to
to sort of
keep being at the vanguard of this
particular movement
then you kind of shouldn't care that
you've got an mba you should just want
to speak your truth
um and and not let other people
do the work that you do not seem willing
to do
um that is me other people might feel
differently i'm sure ray feels
differently
but seeing seeing how people have taken
the slightest crack in the wall
as an opportunity to help tell their
stories
is moving at the least and hopefully you
know will cause
change um at the most
um i am i'm trying to stay out of it
because moon tx
wrote put one of those really sad face
smiley mo
sad emojis where they're looking down
and they've got a
sad face like depressed not mad but it
just says
let mark speak
[Laughter]
you know and like it is it is hard today
to be a buffy fan
you know it's hard today to be an angel
fan you know it's
it's easy to look back at some of the
shows and some of those episodes
especially a thing like dollhouse and
start saying oh geez how do you
make a show where this woman is
essentially just a prostitute who sells
herself out and
kind of devalues what makes her herself
every
every time out every mission she goes on
knowing what we are now beginning to
understand about the man who created it
but yes learning to separate the art
from the artist is an important thing to
do
you know it's especially you know
growing up in the 70s i'm sure people
growing
growing up in the 50s and the 60s and
the movies that they might have loved
were not entirely without trouble even
in the content
not and and the people who made it
it's an exercise we all have to go
through um
you know i think it's it's a valid
valuable one to learn and to learn how
to navigate
and so yeah you you are 100 still
entitled to like buffy
you know buffy's a really important show
for lots of of women
who saw it when they were girls and it
inspired them to
define their power and and to be able to
tackle problems in the world and i i 100
get that and nobody should be able to
take that from you
but we just have to be able to reconcile
that with maybe the man who did that
didn't believe the same things about the
women that he was working with
um i uh did not uh just to
update some cats who were jumping in
they're asking did they talk about wanda
vision oh yes
oh yes we did that was early on in the
show
uh they're asking did we mention gina
carano yes we talked about that as well
um and then a lot of people are trying
to point out to us
we'll get to that in a minute that larry
larry flint died
um i don't this again this ain't me
distancing i just never
fell into the buffy or firefly world
because i was um
i mean i guess it's unfair to say like i
was making things at that point because
like i've enjoyed plenty of things while
i've been a maker of things but that was
just something that
didn't like i saw buffy the vampire
slayer on my birthday in a movie theater
the year it came out
if that counts and i know it doesn't
because it's not nearly the same thing
but you know i was aware of it oh i've
watched a few episodes
when we were about to cast eliza and
jane style and bob strike back because
she had been in the show and stuff
um and then we tried to watch firefly
once me and jen but she wasn't really
like into it and stuff
so i didn't get past one episode so i
you know i've never
you know i think he did a fine job with
the avengers certainly a better job than
i would have and stuff
and uh the uh age of ultron
as well um although he he seemed to get
exhausted by movies based on his
interviews
like all the time it was just like this
is killing me and this is exhausting me
and this is taking a lot out of me and
stuff and
granted i've never made a movie on the
[ __ ] grand scale that he has so
perhaps it does get
tiring and stuff but like you know
i'm always suss of anybody that's like
this is hard man
when it's like come on like i may not
make
sausage as fine as yours but i know how
the sausage is made and
this isn't really hard um i don't really
want to see other people who make movies
of that scale
doing press who don't seem exhausted by
it yeah
he could just be one of those people too
that like you know life tires me and
stuff but um
i um i've in in
you know we've worked with similar
people we've crossed like i've worked
with sarah i've worked with
eliza you know mark lucas
has worked with us a couple times he was
in the buffy world i believe
um but i've you know my crossover with
him
in my entire 20
seven years in this business like i've i
think i've
met him or saw him in person once at
comic-con
and i think we exchanged a tweet before
age of ultron
came out but i was always well aware of
him
as a guy who like me had a very
ardent audience um
so i you know i just have and you know
cursory familiarity with this stuff like
you know
if it was a if he was a category on a
game show
i might be able to run the category like
if it depends who my co-contestants are
but if
the game show was all about joss whedon
i would lose hands down
right so so you'd get to like the 400
question
but then once you get down from there
it's like ah
not even basically i'm like first
question i'm like huh
can i phone a friend no that's not this
show and i was like
because one man mark he loves this [ __ ]
i mean
he really loves it i tell him it's a
little it might be a downfall if that
guy turns out to be a bad guy mark but
he said he'll never turn out to be a bad
guy
now wait a second i'm sorry and i ain't
making light of the situation at all
um you know we're just having fun on the
show with ourselves but you know [ __ ]
anybody who's been victimized by
somebody my heart goes out to but here's
my
and and i'm not asking for like i need
proof but
what is everyone saying that he is done
because it seems very like an overall
he's just shitty like it's not like he
held me down or something like that
although michelle and
i mean not even although there's nothing
like that right
most of it is he created a toxic
workplace environment
and an abusive in in non-specific ways
the most specific thing that came out
was from michelle trachtenberg
who played and i've worked with michelle
on cop-out lovely girl
uh who she said who i [ __ ] in her
tweet she was like now that i'm 36 and i
was like
harriet the spy is 36.
[ __ ] um but she
said you got the quote there i don't
want it
i mean the the quote begins with you
know it must be known as a teenager
um he he did not have the most
appropriate behavior
um what he did was very bad but we win
by surviving
and later she said that there was a rule
that she and joss could not be left
alone in a room together
now if that's a rule that your
showrunner and one of your stars cannot
be in a room together
there's a reason that that rule exists
and how when she was a kid right
she was you know 15 16 maybe
17 by the time she rapped off the show
but she was a young
person definitely not of age now
so did i mean i you know i'm not gonna
be like what do you think that means
mark but
like it doesn't point to anything
positive no it points to more than just
he was mean to people on set
and cruel to people you know behind the
scenes
but generally speaking that seems to be
the predominant
like charge right like i keep reading
these things and it's it just reads like
oh he's just
like shitty and an [ __ ] like the the
the way he there's one article i read
this morning the same guy that guy jose
said his name he said that like whedon
delighted in making writers
cry and one time he made a woman write
her cry and that made him happy or some
such [ __ ]
yeah um chuck lemaine is asking in chat
did they talk about gina carano
where have you people been we've been
doing the show for like an hour
yeah we talked about that [ __ ] now we're
in whedon world man
this is the most uncomfortable show
we've ever done indeed
you know and i think a lot of this is is
about finding context
and his wife his ex-wife um wrote a
letter
um for indie wire i believe like three
or four years ago
um talking about the reasons why they
divorced and his conduct
you know she found herself being
sickened but at the idea
that josh would be able to stand up in
front of a room of women and collect
some kind of award or recognition
for being a feminist when she knows the
man that he was and she
detailed a lot of his behavior inside
their marriage
um infidelities and sort of cruelties
and
you know what seems to be you know onset
affairs with occasional actors
or you know and it's once you start
adding all of these things together it
begins to be a
sort of clear picture you know or the
pictures getting clearer
of a person who abuses power to both
make
people's lives miserable in sort of
toxicity and cruelty
as well as prey on young women who
sort of worshipped them at the altar of
joss whedon
um you know oh and a combination of both
of those
so wait a sec did they just
oh my god jeff's kiss excellent name by
the way
in chat just pointed out two hours
because i was like we've been talking to
[ __ ] for an hour we've already been
doing the show for two [ __ ] hours
yeah um i mean i guess it's like the
wanda vision part
in which you know prior to one division
was the mandalorian part
generally becomes like almost 45 minutes
to an hour in and of itself
yeah we could get away with breaking
this [ __ ]
two shows just the [ __ ] one division
recaps or whatever the show it is we're
watching
and then like just a [ __ ] news show
they're long man this show is longer
than my dick which ain't saying nothing
cause my dick is very very small
very very small yeah so that's the
wheaton stuff you know a rep for him
did not the decline comment to you know
almost everybody who asked
um on both carpenters allegations and
the
further ones but it's you know and again
he did he was asked to leave
the nevers which hbo will be premiering
i believe in april
um which was the show he spent a year
making in london
um his name will still be on it in the
same way that andrew kreisberg's name is
still on every episode of the flash and
supergirl that he worked on because
the guild requires the guild to do what
it does
but you know i don't think they will be
selling it as joss whedon's the nevers
no this go around uh the advent guard
experience in chat says you know why
uh joe rogan got 100 million on spotify
lads
consistency um
well i don't think it was just
consistency that got him
all that money he's also joe attracts
you know huge [ __ ] guests and
yeah that more to do it's not just
because he kept doing shows
like we have been doing this show
forever and
nobody gave us any spotify one hundred
million dollars and stuff
we've done a show almost every week
during the pandemic
yeah that's already consistent he's
important
beyond pop culture he's a cultural
phenomenon of course he got [ __ ]
hundred million dollars
but like you know we're not we ain't
trying to get there oh my god if if we
were trying to make a hundred million
dollars you think we'd be sitting around
talking about juan division
100 million dollars you go [ __ ] make
one division
we're just trying a good time we're just
trying not to get old [ __ ]
indeed uh so that is the end of the
uncomfortable part of the news
amen checky stop sitting right there i'm
gonna keep kicking
all right so as we say goodbye to the
uncomfortable part of the news kids
uh look at this cute dog
there you go this use this as a timeline
washer a wipe of your timeline
now when you talk about fun things in
comics indeed
all right what news mark what more well
uh back in the pedro pascal world
um he has been cast along with uh bella
ramsey for game of thrones
as the leads and the rest ramsay is lady
mormons right
yes she was so awesome remember she got
killed by the giant at the end that was
so heartbreaking
i know she was the the tiniest badass of
game of thrones who is now going to be
a tiny badass in the last of us who used
her in the senate today
and that's all we'll talk about
[Laughter]
you couldn't let it go i mean it just
happened we just got to put the
show in the time span this ain't
political kids we're just making jokes
and [ __ ] but
yes uh she was amazing as
lady mormont likes like a character that
i was like more of this
i'll watch a whole [ __ ] show with a
little girl that runs this bear island
[ __ ]
she's got more sense than all these
[ __ ] um but i wasn't aware of her
doing anything beyond that show
she must have aged up but they keep
showing a picture of her from that
show and she's like [ __ ] nine or ten
like look at this picture
she don't look like that no more because
that was like [ __ ] four years ago
right
yeah yeah so she must look i don't i'm
not familiar with the
this is your thing you play this game
right you love this guy yeah yes
so that girl that we're looking at in
this picture way too young to be in the
girl in your boo
in your game right the girl in the game
is 14 years old and it seems
that that picture is the picture of like
an 11 year old person right right so
she's probably aged up
yeah you know you could probably do a
little bit of of you know between makeup
and
lighting agents mr harvester sorrow says
36
now
jesus what do you think as somebody who
played the game and loved the game
do you approve of this casting is this
something you're into i'm totally into
it i'm here for pedro pascal i'm here
for bella ramsey i'm here
i'm here for the last of us [ __ ]
can't not work man
that guy just like that dude i mean he
must
do he's great like he's you know it's
like all the great actors there's a
reason they hire [ __ ] over and over
again
and like he's getting hired for [ __ ]
where he doesn't even have to prove
himself
at a box office you know what i'm saying
so like
it's at the end of the day he's just
getting work because he's [ __ ] good
he's versatile
charming as [ __ ] and whatnot i've loved
him since well
game of thrones of course but [ __ ] him
and narcospan
yeah there's there's very much like a
young oh at this point now not so young
but burt reynolds
vibe to him yeah where like he's he's a
tough guy
clearly like he's a physical actor
clearly but there's some charm and
there's a there's a wink in his eye
and a sparkle in the way he does stuff
um
and and that's it's a thing that we have
been missing for a while
is just that that young harrison ford
was that thing
and we don't have a ton of that and so
to watch this guy
you know kind of start to sweep up these
plume roles that are asking for that
kind of character
is fun to watch dale m and chat says the
little
lady mormont girl is in uh the golden
compass
not for much though not so much do you
watch that
i did i did why'd you stop
uh well i feel like i've watched
everything that they they've put out so
far
i can't say that i'm a fan but i'm just
i'm kind of
dazzled by how expensive it is it's not
just watching people spend money at a
grand scale
um you know parts of it are kind of fun
parts are interesting maybe if i read
the books it would mean a lot more to me
but you know as a as a person who
attempts
to want to make stuff that feels like
that it's always instructive to watch it
dead gesture in chat says she's 18 now
by the way
so the lady mormont girl is almost the
lady mormont lady
that could that's makes sense they
always cast like 18 year olds to play
[ __ ] teenagers and [ __ ]
yeah i mean honestly it makes the most
sense because now they don't have to
they can work her like an adult and not
as a child if she's gonna be
the second lead to this show i'm the
director and i should be thinking like
that and yet you're the smart one in the
group where you're like
uh legally they could work her like an
adult kid i'm like oh yeah you're
absolute
um all right what else we got um
the cw has ordered uh they're going
heavy on genre
ordering a bunch of new pilots um for
the powerpuff girls show
live action live action coming from i
remember we talked about this and at
first
i was like what the [ __ ] but then i was
like good work good work
so they're they're have they haven't
shot a pilot they're just moving forward
shooting a pilot
correct so they'll be nasting yes
totally because um a show called naomi
which i think we also talked about based
on a comic book from brian michael
bendis and david walker
oh marvel is not a marvel character no
it's dc
it's a dc book um that's right i carry
she's a human character in a world of
the
marvel characters of the dc character
she's non-meta human in the world of
huma uh he met humans
um yes i believe the show will follow a
teenage girl who sets out to discover
the origins of a supernatural event in
her hometown
um ava duvernay is uh producing and
probably directing the pilot along with
arrow veteran jill blankenship um
and that is coming from yeah it is not a
it is not a berlanti jam
which you know it's always hard to find
a non-berlanti show
that's that's kind of crazy yeah melissa
benoist
she just signed a big deal with wb
even though she's wrapping up supergirl
yes next phase in her career
which will involve her making her own
stuff which is super
wonderful actress man like you know she
made that
pun intended she made that supergirl
show fly like
your lead is so [ __ ] charming like
because it's a goofy-ass concept as we
all know but she really
humanized that character she's so
wonderful yeah
and then i'm also doing a reboot of the
4 400. did you ever watch the 4400 back
in the day
isn't that like people disappear and
then they come back
yes there was ultimately like it wasn't
a blip exactly in that like over the
course of time
people had just disappeared um you know
from the
10s and the 20s and the you know 1860s
to the you know 1980s
and then one day all 4 400 of them
returned back to
back to the world some of which you have
like crazy awesome magic powers and [ __ ]
um so yeah it had been a show on on usa
i think it was back in the day
and now they're they're rebooting it and
it's a smart idea and by back in the day
i mean like
2004 or 2007 so it's not like so
it's not an ancient show it's not the
fugitive but
um i'm excited to see it look i love the
idea
i like the uh it was a smart it was a
smart show and we'll see what they do
with the new version of it
um who's involved um
that is coming from blah blah blah blah
blah
cbs studios working with the cw
um but um watching i remember watching
that like
uh i had it on dvd
they were able to fit their entire first
season onto like a two-disc set or
something like that
yeah um but yeah so that's that there
um we had talked a while ago i think
um you know six months maybe a year
huffman on chat says naomi does have
super powers people thought she was a
kryptonian like superman so apparently
she's gonna have powers but also
somebody mentioned in chat
uh a show cw's not making is wonder girl
did you see that
yeah they passed on it yeah what's that
all about like that seemed like an
absolute no-brainer
you know it's it's unclear it's it's
always hard to try and
and kremlinize and get inside the minds
of the reasons why they pick a thing up
or not
you know and it's it's and it's never as
simple as
well the script that they wrote wasn't
good enough or they couldn't find the
right person to cast like there's
there's any number of reasons why the
math didn't work out in its favor
but it is it is unfortunate that uh
that we're not going to get that show
because i think that that was a really
there was an interesting take
on that superhero genre
let's talk about uh a show we are gonna
[ __ ] get
uh they've been dropping these mini
trailers for the big trailer apparently
that's debuting tomorrow
of the snyder cut justice league
the snyder cut and tonight we got our
first look at what looks like the bat
tank from dark knight returns um with
batman standing on top of it
um pretty
i didn't think i was going to see that
in a live action adaptation until they
did the dark knight
returns but man oh man like
didn't he say there was only [ __ ] a
few minutes of new footage
yeah i mean i i think it was something
like you know 10 or 15 minutes of
new i don't know photography was done
and i don't even think it's that high if
i remember correctly for some reason i
thought it was like under 10 minutes
so it feels like with the new footage
like he got like he got to fill in the
cracks and tell the rest of his story
but it'd also sound like he was like
watch this [ __ ] fan service
you know it was just like oh you know i
got the joker i only need him for a few
seconds
i got the bat tank we only need it for a
few seconds very [ __ ] smart man
because
you know there's including little
elements like that as we well know
will completely satisfy a large
cross-section of the audience who's
coming out for that
that's exactly what they're hoping for
they're hoping to see
more cool [ __ ] [ __ ] zack's vision
of cool [ __ ] or zack's you know dc put
through zach's [ __ ]
filter so as long as he packs it with
some [ __ ] like that
it's gonna be incredibly satisfying you
know and it's also hard to tell
you know if if it is just 10 to 15
minutes or even less of new footage
if that's literally just actors on the
stage because that shot of batman on the
bat tank
could be 100 cg yeah oh it's i mean i'm
not i didn't work on it i'm not saying i
know for a fact but i looked at it and i
was like this is fully created because
unless it was shot the first time around
like
we know that ben affleck didn't go back
for re-shoots
so you know now you don't need ben
affleck
to go back to be batman you just need a
guy
in a batman suit particularly for a shot
like that where you're way high overhead
and [ __ ]
but um you know i think it might be tied
into the joker part
of the movie yeah i mean the the more
that they show the more curious i am
um to just see like okay what what is
this
what's in this you know what how much is
it going to differ from the thing that
we saw before
um and and is that difference going to
be
you know a market change on the
experience of seeing it aside from just
being longer
um and dls music wrote at least the
snyder cut will take the weeding out of
justice league
boy talk about a reversal of fortune
right
like one you know [ __ ]
here's zach and josh
joss and on as vis-a-vis justice league
and then it went here's zach and here's
josh
visa v joss vis-a-vis justice league and
now
it went here's zach and here's joss
vis-a-vis justice league and everything
else
like in a very short span of time when
did this justice league picture come out
it was only like two three years ago
yeah it was like 20 i'm gonna say 2016.
i'm not like this ain't like [ __ ]
everybody else but i'm so happy
for like zach like good for him man like
he's i i hope he's doing it right he's
milking it for every [ __ ]
drop it's worth and he's doing it all
right before [ __ ] he drops that
zombie thing on netflix which is gonna
[ __ ] crush
absolutely crush so he's getting all his
propers
that he never got first time around when
you know he had to
pull out of the project and [ __ ] so he
he
i you know i don't know him at all other
than having met him a few times but
i got to imagine he's like feeling good
about [ __ ] right now
like i don't know just on my twitter
algorithm or if it's on like everybody's
trending but like
i he trends almost every day with
something about
justice league you know releasing an
image of the joker or releasing this and
now his trailer tomorrow
um he's you know it reminds me of and
i'm just going to help a segway
the scene and the people versus larry
flint when
he has all the networks at once
like are shooting his story and his
house
and he's in his wheelchair and he starts
spinning around in circles because he's
like ah
like he's in total control of everything
that's what i feel like
zack snyder's got right now like that
kind of clout
credibility man of like i got a thing
that a lot of people want to see and
it's going to rock their [ __ ] world
like i don't even think if it was like
terrible like really terrible abjectly
terrible worse than joss whedon's
that people are going to be able to
differentiate that
because there will be so much i don't
know at least it'll be
in theme with a whole you know what i'm
saying tonally
it will feel like it's supposed to be
there i i'm
happy for him he's got to be like this
has got to be satisfying for him as
a filmmaker as a storyteller to get this
like
last bite at the apple and really
[ __ ] rectify things
and turn it into a bigger deal now than
when it was when it opened
it's kind of that's that's a magic trick
man
for sure take mine so we get a new
trailer for tomorrow
we talked about like maybe doing this
show tomorrow so we could cover it but
we'll just cover it next week and
besides we can never show it anyway we
get
[ __ ] youtube but you're seeing
instagram
seeing the image of the bat tank is like
[ __ ] oh
it's pretty dope man pretty dope it
don't have to make sense
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm not going to be
like hey don't make sense if it don't
make sense like i'm just happy to see
the visual man
he's very v he's very splash page
oriented
and he paints a wonderful splash page
and
you know in a world where i can pause
this show and walk away and take a [ __ ]
and go get food and come back
that running time ain't gonna bother me
in the least man
i am curious to say the least what else
we got
um we talked a while back about
paramount wanting to remake
face-off um which seemed like a fool's
errand
um but they're why i
i don't really know but they're doing it
and so now they brought on uh director
adam wingard
who uh will release godzilla versus kong
shortly
hand kills tried to correct me and say
affleck did come back for additional
photography last october and the
theatrical
cut uh dropped in 2017. i i read
everywhere that affleck did not go back
for
additional photography so
i mean and i don't know that personally
it's not like he told me or something
[ __ ] but i read on the internet that he
did not go back
so i don't know where you're getting
your information but
now that doesn't mean new batman stuff
wasn't shot like we say
it's a guy in a [ __ ] mask so you can
get away with it but the way i
understand it
i he did not go back i know henry cavill
said he did not go back
isn't that right um
j scott for real said the 2017 part is
correct though yeah he went back for the
whedon reshoots we all know that
um really blaming joss for jl
so just all got amnesia for bvs okay
nobody's blaming well i mean
nobody blame it what the [ __ ] does that
mean like
like i don't even know how to explain
that [ __ ] thing like are you saying
that like
this will be bad because it's zach and
batman vs superman
was zack and you didn't like it or
something but
these two things have nothing to do with
the other but nobody was blaming [ __ ]
josh but
we did all see the justice league movie
and
you know it does kind of speak for
itself at least now we get to see
another justice league movie
um practically for free at least if you
have hbo max
so i don't know kev stop reading
comments i just read yours
so what do you want from me should i do
what you told me or not
uh face off yes
don't do it or if you do it do an
in-universe sequel and include both
travolta and and and nick cage again
like they got kids now and those kids
are swapping faces fine
it's not you sean archer it's your kids
but don't
don't whole cloth remake it remember
when they whole cloth remade
robocop and they whole cloth remade uh
um was the [ __ ] schwarzenegger total
recall
like just don't do that
do in-universe sequels continue the
story
people like that yeah or don't do it
just let it be but if you do do it you
got to give it that bot and fink
feeling feeling i'm talking about
[Laughter]
yeah so adam wingard who made your next
and godzilla versus kong is going to try
and remake
um face off you know i wish him luck but
he's talented he makes good movies those
are good movies you know
but it's the the idea is not what made
that movie work it was entirely based on
execution
so you need two incredible performers
yeah
and you need to do the most magnetic
electric scene-eating [ __ ] in
the business man
because that's what kept that movie
alive it's a it's a silly ass concept i
mean i guess no sillier than the marvel
movies but
you know it was those two dudes who made
that movie so [ __ ] fun and watchable
yeah and john woo who knows how to
direct like weird operatic pulp
like few people do dude there's a guy
who knows how to chuck a dove or a
pigeon into a shot i'll tell you what
fly oh my god nightshade holloway goes a
little fruity but i guess that knows
woody's i know that he's doing that's a
barton fancline
um all right one last bit before i guess
we have to to eulogize another person
which
seems to be uh deraguer um our friend
david desmulchen is hosting
fangoria's chainsaw awards oh [ __ ]
number one i love dave despontrum never
not just for his talents and stuff you
know him from the
dar you know the ant-man movies he's the
baba yaga or
in [ __ ] dark knight you know [ __ ]
he was the one that
that uh harvey dent was gonna [ __ ]
shoot
joker stop cooking [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
dave desmond
he's everything he's coming up in
suicide squad yes well he was in jane's
home bob reboot with us first scene in
the beginning
he is such a wonderful actor everyone
loves him they cast him in everything
and stuff
but he's such a good guy yes like such
a good guy with a good heart family man
loves his [ __ ] kids and his wife
such a sweet [ __ ] dude man so i'm
glad
he he's perfect perfect guy to host
fangoria [ __ ] awards i mean the uh
you know he's got that count crowley
book which right in the [ __ ]
same same wheelhouse and stuff yeah i
love to sponsor and he's so awesome
um good for him man it makes me happy
for him it makes me happy that fango
is is enough of a certain brand to have
its own awards
right fangoria folks is a big part of
our childhood and a lot of people might
be like i know what it is but
those of you who grew up with the
internet like before that
those of us who grew up in the 70s and
the 80s we didn't have an internet we
didn't get to like go [ __ ] around and
[ __ ]
and so if you wanted to talk geek or
genre stuff you had star log
or star burst over in the uk and if you
wanted to talk horror stuff you had to
pick up copy fangoria
and you wanted to pick up a copy of
fangoria but sometimes your parents
wouldn't let you because the hot covers
were so [ __ ] horrifying and [ __ ] like
that
but you know it ain't like famous
monsters of film land which was an
amazing
uh monsters uh magazine that been around
for
had been around forever and stuff like
that by force ackerman i think he was
the guy that did it
angoria was just like like you know
[ __ ] us news and world report for
gory horror movies um at a time when we
couldn't get our hands on
[ __ ] like that just anywhere and here
was this glorious [ __ ] magazine
that like talked about all the things
that you loved and [ __ ]
like it was it was the internet before
the internet existed so it is nice to
see the brand
resurging and it's a brand now like
remember back in the day
you know it might be uh what would be
considered uh
like you know uh
what's the word i'm searching for i
smoked it away like not
underground but just so it was a niche
yeah and just also like you wouldn't
[ __ ]
you know bring that around your
grandmother but now we live in a world
where like the internet you can watch
living human beings being killed like
and it will scar you for life according
to jason muse like he was like i watched
somebody get beheaded and i'll never be
the same
again and [ __ ] so in that world like
fangoria
like we've seen true horrors so the idea
of like look at this [ __ ] fake rubber
bloody head
you know isn't as [ __ ] like oh my god
bracing get the [ __ ] out of here you're
going to ruin the children
as it was back in in the 80s it could be
more of a family friendly brand at this
point oddly enough
like horror is far more accepted now
than it was when we were kids in the 80s
and back then it was a lot of like
slasher films and stuff like that
but now horror goes to places like
jordan beale goes
places like um parasite you know
[ __ ] like it's it's such a
wide-ranging field that
fangoria's time like it seems like it
may have come back
i'm very happy for him yeah you know and
fengo was also
this bible for would-be filmmakers
because it was it was one of the few
magazines that was showing a lot of
behind the scenes
how you did this and so you get these
interviews with rob boutin talking about
how he made the thing and then and all
of that
the crazy wolf says spider head [ __ ] sam
rainey would be in there stan winston
would be in there
you know rick baker was all over those
pages and it was very much a
how how do you make a film like this for
next to no money because every horror
movie you love
was made for next to nothing and it
became this sort of
you know a bone of pride i think for a
lot of these filmmakers to be in fango
and as a reader
it was this is how you do it like cine
fantastique
would be the sort of like other sort of
the high end
that was the neiman marcus version of
the phone she was like a wide screen
magazine
so it would have lots of these like 30
page stories about how we made this
in dune or how we made the chess burst
or an alien
but you know fango was you know they
were the same mind but they used like
different fonts to help tell you those
stories about making the movies you
loved if you were a genre fan
two iterations ago because i think this
is this current iteration of fangoria is
completely different
um it was owned for a minute by some
texas people and
[ __ ] went south and it went away or
something i think there was a story
about that last year
but before that company had it right
before i think they went out of business
as a print magazine for the first time
um
they did like me and red state and tusk
on the cover
and for a fango kid
grew up reading that magazine it was
[ __ ]
everything like i didn't make tusk
without thinking
like oh my god if this was the 80s he
would totally be on the [ __ ] cover of
fangoria
but to have them you know as a art
artistic rendering of me and all the my
horror characters was a real
high water mark for me in my career yeah
and it's funny like whenever whenever i
go on meetings
you know you know general meetings in
hollywood a lot of that meeting is you
tell your own story you know you get
about 30 to 40 minutes out of an hour to
tell who you are where you came from
when you like and so on so and then the
next 20 minutes
or whatever the business of the meeting
is and depending on the meeting
i will mention that i was an editor at
fangoria for like four years
and you can see the eyes light up for
the people who knows like
oh [ __ ] fango for real you worked for
fang i was like yeah man i totally did
let me tell you some stories
it's always it's always odd but lovely
to discover those people for whom that
means something
star log fango and remember comic scene
they was uh somebody point old school
shinobi said fangorian star log company
also put out comic scene comic scene was
like
proto wizard if i remember correctly
they sort of existed at the same time
but did not have the cachet
of wizard at all um but yeah i worked
for all three of those
um uh yes
somebody wrote something oh hi lo wrote
i would love to see you guys reaction to
sam raimi's original green goblin design
it'll scare you and your children did
you see
online the like the moving face
version of the green guy they did like a
while back right it was like a test
footage thing and then they decided to
do what they did and you know no
arguments movie made [ __ ] a bunch of
money but
that test version was [ __ ] terrifying
yeah like it looked great but i still
maintain you could have just slapped
green paint on his face give him a few
prosthetics
and [ __ ] willem dafoe when he's in
the mirror in that movie and he just
puts on that rictus grin
it's like you don't need special effects
this guy's a natural man
um all right that's all the news we got
that's all the news if you unless you
want to hit larry flint
larry flint died kids um you know
that's important to us because uh
uh freedom of speech was uh something
that he fought for when he was above
ground
that and naked ladies he fought for that
quite a bit i guess
um one of my favorite movies of all time
is people vs larry flint
such a milos foreman's flick is so so
wonderful so powerful and such a bizarre
love story
um i met or i didn't yeah i did meet
larry flint once
back when they larry flint publications
published uh film threat magazine
back in the day and so i went to speak
to uh
malcolm my friend malcolm was working
there at the time and he brought me in
to say hi to meet chris gore
um who was the editor of film threat and
it was in
the larry flint building and so as we
were going through the like you want to
meet larry i said sure
and he was in his office and they're
like this is larry flynn he was like
thank you
alan that's what he didn't say that
that's what [ __ ] uh
woody harrelson says in the movie when
uh he gets called by the lawyer at the
end
and he goes you won the supreme court
case spoilers
um such a good movie i might go watch
that tonight now
strip for me baby um you got any larry
flint memories
uh i i don't really um aside from
you know i always got the feeling that
if you had to get caught
with pornography um hustler would have
brought you the biggest punishment
um hold on one second i got it now hank
hills is on our chat is going yeah ben
affleck shot a scene with jared leto as
the joker for zack snyder's additional
photography of the snyder cut that is
not true
that's not true i again i don't
i don't know this because i know ben i
haven't spoken to ben and muntz but
the way i understand it and if you look
at that joker shot
there's joker sure and that's jared leto
but there's a guy
in a batman costume you know that don't
mean it's
your guy and again i ain't putting water
out on this because i know anything but
like
everything i read online said that he
then did not go back and do reshoots
for the snyder cut um be careful
what you what you read kids what you
what you believe
um i mean [ __ ] it ain't good enough that
[ __ ] zack snyder gave us granny
goodness did you see that [ __ ]
photo of darkseid dassaud and granny
goodness
granny goodness made me [ __ ] smile so
wide i was like ah
that'll be the first cinematic
representation of granny goodness
not the last because ava duvernay's
working on the new gods right
mm-hmm um
all right that's all the news right give
it up for the heart he gave us all that
[ __ ] news kids
all that sweet sweet news
um okay what uh
jc we need you
we need you where are you
stop interpreting mark kev says gansavi
how when did i interpret mark
oh spelling i think jc abandoned us man
i am watching this [ __ ] show no more
it's too long he's like three [ __ ]
hours of my life i got a baby
would you get this wrapped up jc's gotta
get back to his [ __ ] life kids so
i'm here i just have my here let me do
this one so now you can see my like
bts camera oh look at that [ __ ]
yeah look at it
will everyone see that or is it just
just you you everybody sees my
like yeah i'm green screened over the
city
yes he showed his backstage kids and it
was [ __ ] alarming he ain't wearing
pants he's [ __ ] nipple rubbing he's
crazy
um all right we got some questions jc we
do
i wanted to point out uh a akilah jm
said
uh they'd like to see face off with
jessica chastain and bryce dallas howard
because it wouldn't need any special
effects say that again
the face-off reboot should cast jessica
chastain
and bryce dallas howard because it
wouldn't need special effects
that's actually pretty good man good
observation
that like isle of fisher and somebody
else people are always going like
or amy adams and somebody else maybe
is it amy nyla fisher they're always
like confusing
during uh during star wars episode one
uh keira knightley and natalie portman
were constantly
confused you're absolutely right i
remember that as well yeah that's a
cheap version to do face-off
um and then darth spooky has said uh
somebody saved mr smith from the chat
this isn't a happy place
this is a cursed place it's not a cursed
place and the chat
is like i find the chat to be um a
useful part of
this version of the show they make up
for
the audience version of the show that we
used to do where
we could have instant feedback with
folks in the room and stuff
and the chat is also partly responsible
for like the direction in which
we go and the stuff we talk about so you
know for everybody that's like stop
reading chat i'm like
no like what do you think i want to do
this show in a bubble
i want to know what you're thinking and
i'd like to know what you're thinking in
real time not like after the show
somebody tweeted at me after last week's
show
like why don't you just record the show
and then post it later i was like one
because i don't have
hours and hours to edit the show and two
we're used to doing it in front of
people that chat's what brings the
energy and also we are recording it and
we post it later
it's true we're doing all those things
that everyone's asking about
um there's uh did you see the stanley
book came out by abraham
reisman i did i did have you read it i
got it he sent me a copy of the book
because i talked to him for the book and
stuff
um you know but he gave me a heads up in
advance he's going like
i just want you to know that it's not
you know
it's not like all glorious and stuff
he's going i
took a real level he's like i'm not a
fan but i'm not a non-fan he's going so
i just went in as a journalist
um but you know he he got me ready for a
book that i was like oh my god does it
say that you know he was involved with
nefarious thing
and no like at the end of the day it's
just kind of
more of the you know he took more credit
than he probably deserved
you know that and then when he get into
later in his life with the
peter paul and stan lee me media like
then he peter paul went to jail
apparently there was some
savings and loans scandal there or
something like that
but you know the relatively his his
hands are like relatively clean
there's nothing in the book that i was
like oh my god this i had no idea
sad thing though is they got the
recordings
of him and jc fighting and i've heard
those recordings
like years ago and they're [ __ ]
harrowing to listen to number one you
get to hear stan curse but it ain't in a
fun way like that short
where we you know watched him cartoon
short where he curses
like he's like cursing about her and
it's really [ __ ] heartbreaking and
stuff
but um you know it's abraham's a really
good journalist so it's not like a
hit-and-run job by any stretch of the
imagination but it's
you know definitely a warts and all
story and
you know you take every anything from it
at the end of the day abraham said i
just read a piece
he was like you know there are no such
thing as superheroes
like you know this guy that he like his
heroes he we had feet of clay to some
degree or something like that
i don't want to point out when you say
jc it's not me jc
it's it's stan lee's daughter yeah yeah
our guy jc
the temerity the [ __ ] scream in a
legend no it's stan lee's daughter jc
and like they have there are tapes uh
that
uh somebody gave to abraham so i guess
they're transcribed in the book
of one of their streaming matches and
i'd i'd heard it years ago like
max played played it for me once and it
was like
you know really is heartbreaking
really heartbreaking because you don't
want to like
feel that way about anybody let alone
somebody who's your own
family blood and stuff and you could
hear a man
who had dealt with this for 60 70 years
or something like this was nothing
new um so yeah that's
there it's a you know if you're into if
you want to know about stan lee and the
history of stan lee if you're watching
this show of course
you got some interest in this medium um
the book is out there and it's a kind of
warts and all book but it's also not an
unfair portrayal i didn't think like it
didn't read to me as like a hatchet job
by any stretch of the imagination
um but uh yeah at the end of the day
when you finish the book i guess the
idea is that
you know stan lee was as human as the
rest of us
thankfully there's no like [ __ ]
untoward sex stuff or something like
that
right but it's always like comes down to
the allegations of people going like he
didn't write this stuff but it's like
you have to understand what that or not
i'm not saying i do and you don't but
you know they had to break it down right
somebody had to be a writer somebody had
to be an artist
and you know jack kirby was both
because him and sam would be like you
know have a pre-conversation marvel
method be like oh the story could be
this i wanted this to happen and this
and then jack went off and did whatever
he wanted drew literally whatever he
wanted that makes you a writer
as well so in a fair and just world
it would have said written by stan lee
and jack kirby
art by jack kirby but because the comic
business wasn't worked that way or set
up that way
he said writer stanley artist jack kirby
and um you know he apparently you know
was
based on what i read just very good at
selling himself
like way better at selling himself than
steve ditko was where jack kirby was
stan was a fantastic [ __ ] salesman
and as they
many people have said his greatest
creation wasn't [ __ ] spider-man or
iron man
stan lee's greatest creation was [ __ ]
stan lee he created
the persona of stan lee so i still have
not read anything that has like
turned me off to him and made me go like
oh stan you broke my heart
i i've never you know i only knew him
for the last
20 years of his life 25 years of his
life but
anytime you ever talked about those
characters like stan
created spider-man he would so quickly
shut you down and be like co-created
that was me and steve ditko in as long
as i knew him he was
always telling you who was responsible
along with him he was not hogging the
credit i never met bob kane but i
understand bob kane
made you like people to believe that he
did it [ __ ] all like that's why we
didn't know about
well a lot of people didn't know about
bill finger until a few years ago and
[ __ ]
stan as long as i knew him was not that
guy he did not like
oh i [ __ ] lit all this [ __ ] on fire
it was me
you know he was very quick to be like
that was jack that was steve that was
this one that was that one
so um but you know if you're interested
in the life of stan lee it's a book
definitely worth reading because abraham
is a very good writer
and uh you know it's more info about
stan than
you've ever known you find out about his
family
how he came up and stuff like that um
and he was an ambitious dude the really
sad thing about stan's life to me always
was
he was still waiting to write the great
american novel
like he was like you know this is just
comic books he didn't understand
until the last like say 25 years that
like
you know no that's a [ __ ] that's gonna
that's it that's
that's your massive legacy never mind
the great american novel you wrote the
great american comic book
you know and it's never ending you wrote
an american mythology
so take a bow and um you know he he
wanted he was it sounds like he was
you know hungry for recognition maybe a
little fame hungry
and he didn't realize that the thing
that was going to make him most famous
was the thing that he was working on
his most of his life and you know kind
of looked down at he came you know he
only signed
stan lee because he didn't want people
to know that he worked in comics and he
wanted to save his name stanley lieber
for his book um you know how ironic
uh so it's a is a book worth getting
kids
if you're you know if you're into the
subject of stanley
um all right jc what do we got okay bo h
uh if the guys could remake a john
hughes movie
casting from x-men characters which
movie would you remake
and who would you who would play each
role
so not x-men actors but the actual x-men
who would you cast in a john hughes
movie
doing ferris bueller's day off
and ferris is professor x
because that dude never gets a day off
or wait
do i really want to do a professor x
movie
who deserves a day off oh oh it's got to
be marvel characters
because i was like batman really
deserves a day x-men specifically
well didn't they do that wolverine story
where he goes and gets drunk for a day
or some such [ __ ] so you can't do
wolverine
yeah um i guess i'm sticking with
professor x
he's a dude who's always on the [ __ ]
job and you know maybe he just wants to
[ __ ] around in his dad's car or whatever
[ __ ] go to the circus
in the parade um maybe he wants to
pretend to be the sausage king of
chicago
something like that so it's him
um who's his
cameron well
in the logan movie who was it what was
the guy that the british dude played
from the office
and he play remember in logan the guy
who was looking after
um oh stephen caliban
caliban so i guess that's kind of his
cameron right there
and i guess logan is sloan
[ __ ] they already made the movie they
already made
ferris bueller's day off with mutant
characters and it was called [ __ ]
logan
to go to vegas logan
[Laughter]
what do you got uh i want to do weird
science
good call with uh with cyclops
as gary and
gary our boy her boy what the hell
you're talking about
um colossus is wyatt
and um and jean grey
as uh as the girl as lisa
more jean grey [ __ ] man we've seen
enough jean grey for the last 20 years
it's all wanda time right now
i mean i wouldn't i mean but you know
scarlet witch wasn't an x-man but
she'd also be perfect look at that
[ __ ] there's a guy who knows deep
cuts
he's like some [ __ ] man you piece of
[ __ ]
um all right [ __ ] we did it we did
that one not our best answers but we got
through it it's a tough one
it's tough one who has a curve there
hopefully enjoyed it that was meant to
be more
amusing than informative jason
dino c wants to know since mephisto can
look like anyone
who would you retcon mephisto as in one
of the previous
mcu movies
so when all the mcmu mcu movies how
would you
start mephisto uh
movies before how would i
well what characters so you know at the
end of
we found out that uh you know sam
jackson was actually a
scroll what how would you play mephisto
the same way
hiding him in plain sight i mean sam
seems like the obvious choice because
he's been in every one of the movies and
stuff
and you know morally he's been in gray
or
areas or something um
who else has been there from the
beginning pepper
that pepper [ __ ] pots of [ __ ] i don't
know who
is with her vagina candles and whatnot
um who else can one do you gotta have
somebody that's been around a long time
and oddly enough pepper has been there
from the beginning
but not pepper um
hmm coulson coulson's been around for a
long time and he came back from the
[ __ ] dead
only a devil could do [ __ ] like that
yeah man wouldn't it be great if it was
phil coulson and [ __ ]
because the devil should be like you
know sometimes they play him like oh
hello
i'll eat your [ __ ] but sometimes
[Laughter]
sometimes sometimes he's just like uh
hi how you doing can i help you like
just a helpful guy next door
phil coulson would be my way into
mephisto
hello
i don't know why that tickled me
uh i go i go thunderbolt rocks
oh god that's great that is
[ __ ] great man excellent pull he's
been around since the beginning too
he's been around since the junk you know
and he's always been an antagonist he's
never been
like on the side of really anybody
except himself
and he's always kind of manipulated
events towards
conflict
in chat they're suggesting stan
all the mephisto like i mean that's a
great [ __ ] idea
and a way to keep staying alive in the
movies because they said we're not you
know doing them we're not doing cg
versions of them or something
if all of those [ __ ] moments was
mephisto
except they did do a cg version of him
they did him for for
guardians 2.
it's like young stan and joni in the car
right
no no that wasn't guardians that was uh
end game
and he was still around he was still he
he had shot that before he died
yeah because they younged him up it's
him in the car but they just younged him
up but
kevin foggy said they're not gonna like
try to keep that going now that he's
passed and stuff
um but yeah yeah that is
a stan is an interesting way in
i like your thunderbolt ross man cause
he's such a prick
and it'd be nice to have him playing the
devil bill hurt
he's good what about justin hammer
i [ __ ] love justin hammer don't make
him be the devil because i would just
like to see more justin hammer with
their iron wars coming up
i'm really hoping they bring him back
like he was so [ __ ] electric remember
he [ __ ] danced out onto the stage and
[ __ ]
i i there there are whole montages one
of my favorite moments in a marvel movie
is him going like
is is this a bird in russia
i remember when he was like oh you like
that bird
take his bird the guy raspberries
i got your bird what are you gonna do
so hard um all right what's our next
question our final question
uh dare to tread says
said the ancient one could be
uh uh mephisto which is true she was
[ __ ] or
the ancient one was pulling uh energy
from the dark dimension
but i don't that one she was that
character wasn't in
enough movies i think to be considered
yeah only
two four yeah all right back to you okay
dare to tread wants to know
um which let's see
how can i how can i read this so it
makes sense uh
who do you think from the marvel
universe
would be best suited to be in the dc
universe and vice versa
so like which marvel character would
seamlessly
fit into dc and what dc character would
seamlessly fit into marvel
so like my vote would be i think lobo
would make a great
marvel character good call
i buy that um legion of superheroes feel
like they can easily work
in marvel world um
off the top of my head let me think who
goes from marvel
over to dc though
i feel like the watcher could go from
marvel to dc
that kind of you know big cosmic
kind of all scene all knowing yeah
totally
um but in terms of a
classic superhero it's so interesting
what a great question because it makes
you think like wow
you can't really cross-pollinate these
[ __ ] like
there's a very distinct taste to dc it's
coke and pepsi
right like it's they do a very specific
flavor of superheroes over here
and these cats do a very specific flavor
over there or maybe it's more like root
beer and orange soda but
yeah it's tough what a great question
i've never really thought about that
who from marvel could comfortably be in
dc
i mean you know i guess like hawkeye
because you got a guy with an arrow
running over around in [ __ ] dc as
well bow and arrow
he's the one i think could slide easiest
into dc continuity
you can make him a bad guy for green
arrow or a buddy or something but
at the end of the day it's just a guy
with a [ __ ] quiver full arrows and we
already got one of those so that's the
easiest transition
maybe not the sexiest but it took me a
long time to get to hawkeye because as i
was running through characters i'm like
no
i mean honestly spider-man would work
very well
in a superman universe particularly the
young peter parker
spider-man but he's so iconic
to marvel it's just you know tough to
pull him out of there i can't see
spider-man being friends with batman you
know the way that spider-man can be
friends with
iron man and thor and daredevil or
something like that
i think thor could cross over i think
thor thor in the sort of wonder woman
mythological bent like i think that
could make some sense
you're jeff's kiss you're absolutely
thor
can fully play in [ __ ] wonder woman
world
and and not feel weird at all yeah
that's good paul as well
what a great question though yeah i
think zatanna could go
either way um well
yeah hey now but you know there's always
room for magic users there's always room
for
you know people in fishnets in both of
these universes
um amanda waller could 100 percent be
um a marvel universe sort of
bad guy if you need a bad guy just weird
gray area
operator shield boss
someone said dr doom jay batista i just
feel he's very
marvel to me um
somebody said punisher
you think punisher not in dc
yeah dc you know they don't occur to me
as the killing company
yeah now you got back never kills in the
comics superman who never
kills wonder woman who never kills
aquaman who
well didn't he once kill black manta
after black manta killed his son
yeah and wonder woman did kill max lord
i think
that's right rarely do they kill
yeah a lot of people saying doctor fate
yeah i guess you're right dr fake could
slide into
mark kind of covered it with um
the magic magic characters i think could
slide back and forth
yeah somebody said batman punisher
like crossover batman would want to stop
the punisher
yeah i mean the punisher would be in the
in the dc universe
as a bad guy like the punisher becomes
like deadshot
or like deathstroke um
but not as a hero it's hard to make that
work in the dc universe
a good question i was a brain burner and
then look like really i [ __ ] we
needed phds to be able to answer that
good thing
we've got that kind of experience me and
mark we've been talking about this [ __ ]
since we were children in the 70s kids
ain't a [ __ ] thing you could think of
we ain't already thought of first
no i didn't think of that one that was
really good man somebody said killer
croc is a spider-man villain
uh gambit greedy said that that's a
really good suggestion
um
i mean the joker could be a daredevil
villain
yeah yeah i don't know i mean he could
like if he got enough money but doesn't
feel like he should be the joker still
even though the joker is just a guy
he still feels like a force of nature
you know
like matt murdock always felt like a
street thug
fighter and the joker while he is
nothing more than a guy with [ __ ]
makeup and [ __ ] like i can't think of
the aggregate
that daredevil ever fought except maybe
typhoid mary who we also
had sex with they had a relationship so
they would fight
and [ __ ] very twisted and nicenti wrote
those remember the typhoid mary issues
of [ __ ] daredevil
um i can't believe we were just talking
comic books
instead of comic book movies or tv shows
remember remember the origin of the ship
kids uh that's it for the questions
my friend jc
that's all the cues they asked three
we gave him three 726 we've now been
doing the show for three [ __ ] hours
indeed it's like we're a telethon jerry
lewis coming out next
i can feel the hair of my balls growing
we've been doing this for long
enough you know how to fix that
manscape.com
special code fat man 20. kids
don't get caught with hair on your balls
nobody likes that nobody
use the force
nobody likes that here man i'll show you
this [ __ ] in action
oh [ __ ] did i [ __ ] it up
no good why you could never [ __ ] up
with it what do they call it lawn
[ __ ] up with the lawn mower the
manscaped longer
more go to manscape.com ladies and
gentlemen the code is fatman20
get some money off and stuff show our
sponsor a little love so we keep getting
some sponsors
um that way we can do three hour [ __ ]
shows that never end
somewhere we got families wondering what
happened to us
all three of us so we're going to go
back to them right now
did you enjoy yourselves kids if you did
is because that dude right there
went and looked up uh well first is
because that dude right there
[ __ ] right below me oh i can touch
this one i'm crushing your head
um jc made it all possible give it up
for jc
and then of course there is nothing that
happens in fat man beyond
without uh the other guy over there give
it up for the great mark bernard ladies
and gentlemen thank you boys and girls
uh tomorrow is the season finale of your
honor have you been watching that on
showtime
i have not is it good never mind jeff's
kiss
jeff's [ __ ] it's so [ __ ] good
honestly i need you to watch it because
as a writer
i think you'll be enthralled you'll be
like wow
they really found a way to twist this
and twist this and twist this
and keep it compelling if the point of
drama
is to create a problem for your
protagonist and then have him solve it
or her solve it over the course of
whatever it is
they have done an exceptional job of
throwing their protag
curves at their protagonists left and
right uh brian cranston is as
always amazing playing another you know
morally sketchy character but this time
for reasons
that are compelling i'm not saying
breaking bad wasn't compelling but
personally compelling to him um you
gotta
check it out it's so well done so
[ __ ] well done so
smartly written um brilliantly acted
definitely worth checking out
i'm sure somebody's like you're a
[ __ ] chill for showtime no i'm not i
just like this [ __ ]
kids do you hear me talk about things
that's because i really
like them um if you don't hear me talk
about things
that's because a i don't watch them or b
i don't really like them
but you'll never hear me talk about [ __ ]
that i like because i got paid
to like it that just doesn't happen like
it really does
i wish it [ __ ] did we're on the show
every week talking about how much we
love this that or the other thing
they don't even give us free copies of
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying like who sucks
more [ __ ] marvel dick than us
we didn't get no early previews of the
[ __ ] show before it came on
so trust me man there's this ain't no
chilery this is just love this affection
i'm a 50 year old [ __ ] man i'm only
going to talk about this [ __ ]
if it gets me [ __ ] happy and it does
make me happy and that's why we do this
every week
you being here as part of the happiness
man reading the chat
finding hearing your feelings we don't
do this in a vacuum we do it because we
wanted to
hear from you as well this is one of the
best parts of my week i'm so glad we got
to do it
we'll do it again next week gentlemen on
saturday indeed
there'll be more wanda vision an hour's
worth of it to talk about
ooh there'll be a four-hour show we'll
also go over the
the snyder cut trailer which will be a
week old at that point but still
we'll cover all the news that [ __ ] to
print ladies and gentlemen that's what
we do
here fat man beyond that's all
we're going to give you this week for
fat man beyond we just gave you the tip
now we're going to take it away till
next week ladies and gentlemen for fat
man beyond
i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernard tune in
next time same fat time same fat
channel smodcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith jeff's kiss
you